HUMAN RESOURCE. ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION. ENERGY WILL COME TO
ORDER. SHOULD WE STOP? OKAY. NO
QUORUM NEEDED. I HAVE A FEW
OPENING REMARKS, AND THEN WE
WILL HEAR FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. TODAY WE'RE GOING TO
HEAR ABOUT THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISION PROPOSALS IN THESE
AREAS OF RESOURCES.
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AND
ENERGY. WE DO KNOW, OF COURSE,
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET WILL BE
TOUGH. ONE, EVEN AFTER OUR EARLY
ACTIONS, WE STILL HAVE AN
ESTIMATED $27 BILLION PLUS
SHORTFALL. WE'RE GOING TO HEAR
PROPOSALS TO MAKE UP THAT
SHORTFALL THROUGH CUTS AND
DELAYS, IN OUR AREA AND BUDGET
SUB TWO, AS WELL AS FUND SHIFTS
TO OTHER SPECIAL FUNDS IN
PARTICULARLY THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND, I WILL NOTE FROM
THE OFFSET AND WE WILL HEAR THIS
FROM SURE. AS WE GO ON THAT I
THINK THERE'S REASON TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT NEW AND NOVEL
USES OF GRF THAT ARE BEING
PROPOSED HERE BY THE
ADMINISTRATION. THE MAY REVISION
SHIFTS A NUMBER OF PROGRAMS,
INCLUDING 20 MILLION FOR
REGIONAL FOREST AND FOR OUR
CAPACITY VÆ, SOME 50 MILLION
FOR, WELL, PLUG AND ABANDONMENT,
75 MILLION FOR THE SALTON SEA,
BUT MORE SPECIFICALLY, OTHER
CHARACTER CATEGORIES THAT WILL
GO INTO THAT IT HAVE A MORE
TENUOUS CONNECTION TO REDUCING
GREENHOUSE GASES, THAT MAY
REVISE ALSO PROPOSE TO SHIFT 1.3
BILLION OF INTO GRF FOR TRANSIT
PROGRAMS. THIS IN ADDITION TO
THE CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION
APPROPRIATIONS TO HIGH SPEED
RAIL FUNDED AT $1 BILLION THIS
BUDGET YEAR AND THE TERCET
PROGRAM FUNDED AT $400 MILLION
TO THE THIS BUDGET YEAR. SO I
WANT TO BE CLEAR. ALL THESE
PROGRAMS ARE ARE VERY WORTHY AND
IMPORTANT, PROGRAMS, BUT I AM
CONCERNED IF WE'RE NOT
PRIORITIZING EMISSIONS REDUCTION
PROGRAMS FOR GRF, THAT THAT IS,
GOING TO COME BACK TO BITE US IF
WE WHEN WE WORK ON RENEWAL, THIS
PROGRAM, THIS IS REALLY OUR
MONEY TO FUND GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTIONS. AND WE NEED TO KEEP
THE FOCUS ON THAT. AND IN THIS
TIME BUDGET DIFFICULTY, WE'LL
NEED TO PRIORITIZE THE MOST
EFFECTIVE PROGRAMS TO MAXIMIZE
THE IMPACT OF OUR STATE DOLLARS
IN REACHING OUR AMBITIOUS
CLIMATE GOALS. SO I LOOK FORWARD
TO HEARING MORE FROM THE
MINISTRATION TODAY ABOUT THE
PROPOSALS FROM THE LAB ON THEIR
COMMENTS AND DISCUSSION, FROM MY
COLLEAGUES AS WE BEGIN OUR
BUDGET DISCUSSIONS REGARDING THE
MAY REVISION. AND WITH THAT, I'D
LOVE TO CALL UP THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE TO, BEGIN TO PRESENT
.
SURE. GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING.
CHAIR. MEMBERS SUR LA DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. TO START OFF WITH
JUST PROVIDING A KIND OF HIGH
LEVEL OVERVIEW OF THE CURRENT
BUDGET PICTURE. AND THEN GO INTO
SOME OF THE SPECIFICS OF WHAT'S
INCLUDED WITHIN THE MAY
REVISION, BOTH ON THE GENERAL
FUND SOLUTION SIDE AND THEN SOME
Kò BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSALS AND
TRAILER BILL ALSO IN THE MAY
REVISION. SO IN JANUARY, THE
BUDGET PROJECTED A SHORTFALL FOR
THE END OF THE 2425 FISCAL YEAR
OF ROUGHLY $38 BILLION. BUT
CONDITIONS SINCE THEN HAVE
WORSENED FOR A TOTAL OF $7
BILLION AND WITHOUT ACTION, THE
ESTIMATED TOTAL SHORTFALL FOR
THE BUDGET YEAR WOULD BE $45
BILLION. BUT LAST MONTH, THE
LEGISLATURE DID ENACT AN EARLY
ACTION, A PACKAGE ACKNOWLEDGING
THE IMPORTANCE TO BEGIN TO CLOSE
THE SHORTFALL BY $17.3 BILLION,
WHICH STILL WITHIN THE BUDGET
WINDOW, LEAVES A SHORTFALL OF
$27.6 BILLION. AT THE SAME TIME,
EVEN WITH THE SOLUTIONS
ADMINISTRATION STILL PROJECTS
MULTI BILLION DOLLAR SHORTFALL
ALSO WITHIN THE 2526 FISCAL YEAR
AND THE GOVERNOR DOES BELIEVE IT
IS IMPORTANT TO SOLVE THE
ESTIMATED SHORTFALL FOR TWO
FISCAL YEARS, NOT JUST ONE, IN
ORDER TO PUT THE STATE IN A MORE
SUSTAINABLE PATH FOR THOSE
FUTURE YEARS. SO THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSES AN ADDITIONAL
SET OF SOLUTIONS THAT WOULD ALSO
CLOSE THE SECOND YEAR SHORTFALL
BY AN ESTIMATED $28.4 BILLION.
NOW IT GOES AS SAYING THIS IS
NOT AN EASY TASK, AND BY
DEFINITION, MANY HARD CHOICES
HAVE TO BE MADE. AND AS THE
GOVERNOR ALSO ALLUDED TO IN THE
PRESS CONFERENCE, THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF PROPOSALS IN THE MAY
VISION THAT HE WOULD EVEN PREFER
NOT TO PUT FORWARD. BUT MANY OF
THESE INVOLVE PROGRAMS THAT BOTH
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
HAVE WORKED CLOSELY TOGETHER TO
ADVANCE IN THE PAST FEW YEARS.
BUT GIVEN THE SCOPE OF THE
SHORTFALL, THESE ARE THE KINDS
OF MEASURES THE GOVERNOR
BELIEVES HAS TO BE PUT FORWARD
FOR CONSIDERATION IN ORDER TO
BRING THE BUDGET BACK INTO
BALANCE, NOT JUST FOR THIS
COMING YEAR, BUT ALSO FOR THE
NEXT FISCAL YEAR AS WELL. SO THE
MAJOR REVISION PROPOSES OR,
REPRESENTS THE BEGINNING OF THE
PROCESS AND DISCUSSIONS AND
NEGOTIATIONS ON A FINAL BUDGET
AGREEMENT. BUT THE
ADMINISTRATION DOES STAND READY
TO WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE
OVER THE NEXT COMING WEEKS, AS
THESE DISCUSSIONS CONTINUE AND
ALSO TO HEAR OTHER ALTERNATIVES
PROPOSED BY THE LEGISLATURE. SO
THE 21 AND 2022 BUDGET ACT
ALLOCATED APPROXIMATELY $54
BILLION OVER A FIVE YEAR PERIOD
TO ADVANCE THE STATE CLIMATE
AGENDA. AND WITH THIS REVISION,
THE BUDGET DOES MAINTAIN 45
BILLION, OR 83% OF THESE
INVESTMENTS OVER AN EIGHT YEAR
PERIOD AND APPROXIMATELY $33
BILLION OF THIS FUNDING HAS
ALREADY BEEN APPROPRIATED TO
DEPARTMENTS, WITH THE REMAINING
12 BILLION SET TO BE
APPROPRIATED OVER THE NEXT
FISCAL YEARS AND THE BUDGET DOES
CONTINUE TO PRIORITIZE EQUITY
AND INVESTMENTS IN PRIORITY
POPULATIONS THAT FACE
DISPROPORTIONATE, IMPACT FROM
POLLUTION AND THE CLIMATE
CRISIS. AND WE ALSO DO CONTINUE
TO SEEK AND LEVERAGE FEDERAL
FUNDING AND AS OF THE END OF
APRIL, THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
OR CALIFORNIA AS A WHOLE IS
ESTIMATED TO GET ABOUT $15.9
BILLION IN ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
FUNDING THROUGH THE INFLATION
REDUCTION ACT AND THE
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS AND
JOBS ACT, FOR CLIMATE RELATED
PROGRAMS. NOW, THE MAYOR OF
VISION PROPOSES A COMBINATION OF
MEASURES THAT INCLUDES AN
ADDITIONAL APPROXIMATELY $7.2
BILLION IN GENERAL FUND
SOLUTIONS FOR CLIMATE RELATED
PROGRAMS, 3.6 BILLION BEING
REDUCTIONS AND 3.6 BILLION BEING
SHIFTS TO THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND. THE MAYOR VISION
INCLUDES A COMPREHENSIVE CAP AND
TRADE EXPENDITURE PLAN THAT
ALLOCATES THE DISCRETIONARY CAP
AND TRADE REVENUES OVER THE NEXT
FOUR YEARS TO PRIMARILY SUPPORT
SHIFTS FROM THE GENERAL FUND AND
THE MAYOR VISION ALSO INCLUDES A
REEVALUATION OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET CAP AND TRADE SHIFTS, TO
REPRIORITIZE PROGRAM
EXPENDITURES. AND THIS HOLISTIC
APPROACH OF ALLOCATING CAP AND
TRADE OVER THE NEXT FEW YEARS
HELPS ADDRESS A SIGNIFICANT
BUDGET DEFICIT, BOTH IN THE
BUDGET YEAR AND ALSO IN THE OUT
YEARS, AND ALSO HELPS PROTECT
MANY OF THE COMMITMENTS THAT WE
HAVE MADE WITH THE LEGISLATURE
ON THESE PRIORITY CLIMATE
PROGRAMS OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS. THE MAYOR VISION ALSO
INCLUDES AN ADDITIONAL 540
MILLION IN NON CLIMATE NATURAL
RESOURCES, ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION RELATED PROGRAMS AND
THIS INCLUDES 234 IN REDUCTIONS,
300 MILLION AND 234 MILLION IN
REDUCTIONS, 300 MILLION IN
REVENUE BORROWING AND THEN AN
ADDITIONAL 606 MILLION IN FUND
SHIFTS NOT RELATED TO GQF. THE
MAYOR VISION ALSO INCLUDES, A
FEW EROSIONS, AND ONE PROPOSED
TO HIGHLIGHT IS, THE BEVERAGE
CONTAINER RECYCLING FUND LOAN
THAT WAS PROPOSED BY GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET THAT IS PULLED BACK IN
THE MAY REVISION, SO NOT LONGER
MOVING FORWARD WITH THAT
PROPOSED, LOAN, JUST
ACKNOWLEDGING THE CONDITION OF
THE FUND, THE ADMINISTRATION'S
GENERAL FRAMEWORK, WHEN LOOKING
AT CLIMATE AND NATURAL RESOURCES
RELATED PROGRAMS AND SOLUTIONS.
ÓRDENES FIRST, WE IDENTIFIED
WHAT PROGRAMS STILL HAD MONEY
AND WHAT FISCAL YEAR. SO WE
ANALYZE THE STATUS OF ALL THE
PREVIOUSLY APPROPRIATED
PROGRAMS, AND JUST ONE THING TO
NOTE IS MUCH OF THE CLIMATE
FUNDING THAT HAS BEEN INCLUDED
IN THE CLIMATE BUDGETS, THE
MULTIYEAR CLIMATE BUDGETS, MUCH
OF IT HAS ALREADY BEEN
ENCUMBERED AND REALLY ISN'T
AVAILABLE FOR SOLUTIONS. AND SO
WE JUST LOOKED AT THE SCOPE OF
WHAT'S REMAINING. WE ALSO LOOKED
AT POTENTIAL AVAILABILITY TO
SHIFT TO OTHER FUNDS, INCLUDING
GRF. WE LOOKED AT THE PREVIOUS
REDUCTIONS AND SHIFTS THAT WERE
MADE IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET.
GIVEN THAT LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
ALREADY INCLUDED SEVERAL
SOLUTIONS AND SEVERAL SHIFTS TO
CAP AND TRADE, SO THAT WAS
CONSIDERED AS WE WERE LOOKING AT
NEW POTENTIAL MÀ SOLUTIONS IS,
OF COURSE, LOOKING AT
PRIORITIZING EQUITY AND
INVESTMENTS IN PRIORITY
POPULATIONS FACING HARM FROM
POLLUTION AND CLIMATE CRISIS.
AND THEN ALSO JUST LOOKING AT
WHAT PROGRAMS ALIGN WITH SOME OF
THE HIGHEST CLIMATE PRIORITIES
OF THE ADMINISTRATION. AND THEN
LASTLY, WHERE SOME OF THAT 15.9
BILLION IN FEDERAL INVESTMENTS
COULD POTENTIALLY OFFSET AT A
HIGH LEVEL, YOU KNOW, SOME OF
THE POTENTIAL LOSS IN GENERAL
FUND, JUST FROM THE LARGER, YOU
KNOW, CLIMATE PROGRAM
PERSPECTIVE. AND ULTIMATELY,
THERE ARE MANY TOUGH CHOICES
THAT ADMINISTRATION HAD TO MAKE
IN ORDER TO PUT TOGETHER A
BALANCED BUDGET TO MEET OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL MANDATE. AND SO
WITH THAT, I'M ACTUALLY GOING TO
TURN IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE
STEPHEN BENSON, WHO'S GOING TO
GO INTO A LITTLE BIT MORE DETAIL
ON SOME OF THE PROPOSED CHANGES
IN THE MAY REVISION. THANK YOU.
STEPHEN BENSON WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I'LL JUST
DO A SUMMARY OF THE KEY
SOLUTIONS, AS WELL AS SOME KEY
NEW INVESTMENTS THAT ARE
PROPOSED IN THE REVISION. SO
STARTING WITH THE CLIMATE
CATEGORY, PACKAGES FOR ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES, THE 2122
BUDGET ACT COMMITTED $10 BILLION
OVER FIVE YEARS IN INVESTMENTS
FOR THE STATE'S ZEV AGENDA. THE
MAYOR VISION MAINTAINS 9.7
BILLION, OR 96% OF THESE
INVESTMENTS, AND INCLUDES A
GENERAL FUND REDUCTION OF 383
MILLION ACROSS FOUR PROGRAMS, A
DELAY OF 99 MILLION FROM GQF
WITHIN GRF FOR ZEV, FUELING
INFRASTRUCTURE, AND A GRF
REDUCTION AND DELAY FOR THE ZERO
EMISSION TRANSIT CAPITAL
PROGRAM. FOR WATER AND DROUGHT.
THE 20 2122 BUDGET ACTS
COMMITTED
YEARS IN INVESTMENTS TO SUPPORT
WATER AND DROUGHT RESILIENCE
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. THE MAYOR
OF VISION MAINTAINS 6.6 BILLION,
OR 76% OF THESE INVESTMENTS, AND
INCLUDES A GENERAL FUND
REDUCTION OF 673 MILLION AND A
$586 MILLION SHIFT FROM GENERAL
FUND TO GRF ACROSS VARIOUS
PROGRAMS FOR WILDFIRE FORCE
RESILIENCE. THE 2122 BUDGET ACTS
COMMITTED TO 2.8 BILLION FOR
WILDFIRE AND FORCE RESILIENCE.
THE MAYOR VISION MAINTAINS 2.6
BILLION, OR 93% OF THESE
INVESTMENTS AND INCLUDES THE
GENERAL FUND REDUCTIONS OF 44.1
MILLION ACROSS FIVE PROGRAMS, 30
MILLION IN FUND SHIFTS TO THE TO
GRF ACROSS TWO PROGRAMS, AND 128
MILLION IN DELAYS TO GRF ACROSS
THREE PROGRAMS FOR EXTREME HEAT,
THE 21, 22, 2021 AND 2022
CLIMATE BUDGETS COMMITTED 649
MILLION FOR EXTREME HEAT. THE
MAYOR VISION MAINTAINS 268
MILLION, OR 41% OF THESE
INVESTMENTS, AND INCLUDES A
GENERAL FUND REDUCTION OF 2
MILLION FOR GREEN SCHOOLYARDS
AND A $93.8 MILLION GRF
REDUCTION FOR EXTREME HEAT AND
COMMUNITY RESILIENCE AND URBAN
GREENING PROGRAMS FOR NATURE
BASED SOLUTIONS. THE 20, 2021
AND 2022 BUDGET ACTS COMMITTED
1.6 BILLION FOR NATURE BASED
SOLUTIONS. THE MAYOR VISION
MAINTAINS 1.4 BILLION, OR 88,
AND INCLUDES A GENERAL FUND
REDUCTION OF 25 MILLION ACROSS
TWO PROGRAMS AND 232 MILLION IN
FUND SHIFTS TO THE GRF ACROSS
FOUR PROGRAMS FOR COASTAL
RESILIENCE. THE 2021 AND 2022
BUDGET ACTS COMMITTED 1.3
BILLION FOR COASTAL RESILIENCE.
THE MAYOR OF VISION MAINTAINS
653 MILLION, OR 50% OF THESE
INVESTMENTS, AND INCLUDES A
GENERAL FUND REDUCTION OF 6.7
MILLION FOR SEA LEVEL RISE.
ADAPTATION IN STATE PARKS, A
SHIFT OF 27.5 MILLION OCEAN
PROTECTION FUNDING TO TWO GQF
AND A DELAY OF 36.8 MILLION GRF
FOR SB ONE IMPLEMENTATION FOR
COMMUNITY RESILIENCE, THE 2021
2022 BUDGET ACTS COMMITTED 1.9
BILLION FOR COMMUNITY RESILIENCE
INVESTMENTS TO ADVANCE CLIMATE
RESILIENCE AND LOW INCOME AND
UNDERREPRESENTED COMMUNITIES.
THE MAYOR OF VISION MAINTAINS
1.2 BILLION, OR 67% OF THESE
INVESTMENTS, AND INCLUDES A
SHIFT OF 14.4 MILLION TO GRF FOR
THE CLIMATE. CALIFORNIA CLIMATE
ACTION CORPS AND ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ACTION GRANTS PROGRAM IN
AGRICULTURE FOR THE 2021 AND
2022 BUDGET ACTS ALLOCATED 1.1
BILLION FOR SUSTAINABLE
AGRICULTURAL PROGRAMS TO ADAPT
TO CLIMATE CHANGE AND REDUCE
CARBON EMISSIONS. THE MAYOR
VISION MAINTAINS $1 BILLION, OR
89% OF THESE INVESTMENTS, AND
INCLUDES A $10.6 MILLION
REDUCTION AND A DELAY OF GRF FOR
THE LIVESTOCK METHANE REDUCTION
PROGRAM FOR ENERGY. THE 2021 AND
2022 BUDGET ACTS COMMITTED 7.9
BILLION OVER FIVE YEARS, AND
STATE CLEAN ENERGY INVESTMENTS.
ADDITIONALLY, SB 846 INCLUDES $1
BILLION OVER THREE YEARS TO FUND
ACTIVITIES UNDER THE CLEAN
ENERGY RELIABILITY INVESTMENT
PLAN. THE MAYOR VISION MAINTAINS
5.5 BILLION, OR 69% OF THE
ORIGINAL ENERGY INVESTMENTS AND
FULLY FUNDS SIRUP. THE MAYOR'S
VISION INCLUDES 1.6 BILLION IN
ADDITIONAL GENERAL FUND
REDUCTIONS, PARTIALLY OFFSET BY
539 MILLION OF ADDITIONAL GRF
COMPARED TO THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. ADDITIONALLY, 900
MILLION OF THE SIRUP INVESTMENT
INITIATIVE IS PROPOSED TO BE
FUNDED USING GRF IN FUTURE YEARS
INSTEAD OF GENERAL FUND AND THEN
SWITCHING TO SOME NON CLIMATE
PACKAGE RELATED SOLUTIONS, THE
MAYOR VISION INCLUDES A ONE TIME
SHIFT OF GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND TO THE TIMBER
REGULATION AND FOREST
RESTORATION FUND. SO THE MAYOR
VISION PROPOSES TO REDUCE THE
$200 MILLION GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND THAT'S
APPROPRIATED TO CAL FIRE
ANNUALLY BY $120 MILLION FOR ONE
YEAR IN 2024 AND 25, AND
PROPOSES TO BACKFILL THAT WITH
$120 MILLION FROM THE TIMBER
REGULATION AND FOREST
RESTORATION FUND. SO THE TOTAL
AMOUNT OF FUNDING FOR THE
WILDFIRE ACTIVITIES WILL REMAIN
AT $200 MILLION, BUT IT SWITCHES
120 OF THAT FROM GRF TO TR FIRF,
AS WE CALL IT, AND THEN USES
THAT $120 MILLION OF GRF IN TURN
TO COVER OTHER GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURES AS PART OF THE
OVERALL CAP AND TRADE
EXPENDITURE PLAN, THERE'S ALSO A
PCF LOAN IN THE MAYOR VISION, IT
PROPOSES A $300 MILLION LOAN
FROM THE AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
FUND TO THE GENERAL FUND TO
ASSIST IN CLOSING THE PROJECTED
SHORTFALL AND ENSURING THE
SUBMISSION OF A BALANCED BUDGET
PLAN. THE BALANCE IN THE FUND
PRIMARILY CONSISTS OF VARIOUS
FINES AND SETTLEMENTS REGARDING
THE HABITAT CONSERVATION FUND,
THE MAYOR VISION PROPOSES
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO
ACCELERATE THE SUNSET DATE FOR
GENERAL FUND TRANSFERS TO THE
HABITAT CONSERVATION FUND, AS
WELL AS BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE TO
REVERT 45 MILLION IN EXISTING
TRANSFERS BACK TO THE GENERAL
FUND FOR OUTDOOR EQUITY GRANTS.
THE 2021 AND 22 BUDGET ACTS
ALLOCATED $115 MILLION FOR
OUTDOOR EQUITY GRANT PROGRAMS
ESTABLISHED BY CHAPTER 675
STATUTES OF 2019, WHICH WAS AB
209. THE MAYOR VISION INCLUDES A
REDUCTION OF $50 MILLION FOR
THIS PROGRAM, WHICH MAINTAINS 60
MILLION OR 44, WHICH HAS ALREADY
BEEN AWARDED FOR LOAN LOSS.
RESERVE PROGRAM. THE MAYOR
VISION INCLUDES A GENERAL FUND
REDUCTION OF $175 MILLION IN
2022, 20 2324. $150 MILLION IN
20 2425. $175 MILLION IN 20 2526
FOR A TOTAL REDUCTION OF $500
MILLION. THIS CHANGE ELIMINATES
FUNDING FOR THIS PROGRAM
REGARDING CLEANUP AND VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES INITIATIVE. TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE. THE MAYOR VISION
INCLUDES A GENERAL FUND
REDUCTION OF 268.5 MILLION,
INCLUDING 136,000,000 IN 2023,
24, 85,000,000 IN 20 2526, AND
47.5 MILLION IN 20 2627. THE
MAYOR VISION ALSO INCLUDES A
FUND SHIFT OF 108 MILLION TO GRF
175 MILLION WAS PROPOSED FOR
DELAY AT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
THIS. OVERALL, THIS WILL ALL
MAINTAIN 231.5 MILLION, OR 46%
OF THE TOTAL ALLOCATION FOR THIS
PROGRAM. AND FINALLY, I'M GOING
TO SUMMARIZE A COUPLE OF THE KEY
MAYOR VISION BCP'S LIKE NEW
PROPOSALS, SO FIRST OFF, FOR
FRUIT, FOR FRUIT. YEAH, FOR
FRUIT FLIES, THE MAYOR VISION
INCLUDES A REQUEST OF
APPROXIMATELY $25 MILLION, ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND AND $28.8
MILLION ONE TIME FEDERAL TRUST
FUND AUTHORITY IN 24 2024 25 TO
CONTINUE EFFECTIVELY RESPONDING
TO THE UNPRECEDENTED PRESENCE OF
INVASIVE FRUIT FLIES. THIS
ADDITIONAL FUNDING IS ESSENTIAL
TO SWIFTLY ERADICATE THESE
INVASIVE PESTS. TO PREVENT THEM
FROM ESTABLISHING IN CALIFORNIA
AND IRREVOCABLY ALTERING THE
STATE'S AGRICULTURE INDUSTRY.
RELATED TO THE LEVIATHAN MINE,
THE MAYOR VISION INCLUDES A
REQUEST FOR $3.7 MILLION ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND IN 20 2425 OF
THAT AMOUNT, 3.5 MILLION WILL
FUND CRITICAL PERFORMANCE
EFFICIENCY AND SAFETY
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE AGING POND
WATER TREATMENT SYSTEM AND THE
LEVIATHAN MINE SUPERFUND SITE AT
THE LEVIATHAN MINE SUPERFUND
SITE, $200,000 WILL ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
TO EFFECTUATE A POSSIBLE
TRANSFER OF TITLE FOR THE SITE
FROM THE STATE TO ATLANTIC
RICHFIELD COMPANY, WHICH HAS
EXPRESSED AN INTEREST IN
OBTAINING THE TITLE TO THE SITE
AND DILIGENT EFFORTS ARE BEING
MADE BY THE STATE WATER BOARD,
LAHONTAN REGIONAL WATER BOARD,
AND THE ATLANTIC RICHFIELD
COMPANY TO FINALIZE AN
AGREEMENT. THE MAYOR VISION ALSO
INCLUDES A REVERSION OF
APPROXIMATELY $5.2 MILLION FOR
THE VÌ THÀNH CREEK DIVERSION
CHANNEL RELINING PROJECT. IF THE
POSSIBLE TRANSFER OF OWNERSHIP
OF THE STATE IS REALIZED,
POTENTIAL FUTURE LIABILITY FOR
THE STATE WILL BE SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCED BECAUSE THE STATE WILL
NO LONGER BE PROPERTY OWNER. IN
REGARDS TO HAZARDOUS WASTE
CONTROL ACCOUNT, THE GENERATION
AND HANDLING FEE SHORTFALL
SOLUTION. THE MAYOR VISION
INCLUDES A NET ZERO OR SORRY, A
NET INCREASE OF $750,000 IN
2024, 25 AND $500,000 ONGOING,
WHICH INCLUDES A DECREASE OF 4.6
MILLION TO THE HAZARDOUS WASTE
CONTROL ACCOUNT AND AN INCREASE
OF 5.3 MILLION TO OTHER FUNDS TO
ADDRESS THE GENERATION AND
HANDLING FEE REVENUE SHORTFALL.
THESE DOLLARS WOULD PROVIDE
IMPROVED OVERSIGHT OF WASTE
GENERATION, INCREASED FEE PAYER
COMPLIANCE FOR GENERATED WASTE,
AND MORE CONSISTENT ADHERENCE TO
STATUTORY EXEMPTIONS FROM THE
FEE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE WILL
ACCOMPANY THIS PROPOSAL TO
CLARIFY THE STATUTE TO MORE
CLOSELY ALIGN WITH THE
ORIGINATING INTENT FOUND IN SB
158 SUPPORT OVERSIGHT AND
COMPLIANCE EFFORTS. CLARIFY THE
FEE CALCULATION AND CLARIFY HOW
EXEMPTIONS ARE USED IN THE
FUTURE. ADDITIONALLY THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES TO
FORGIVE A $15 MILLION LOAN MADE
FROM THE TOXIC SUBSTANCES
CONTROL ACCOUNT TO THE HAZARDOUS
WASTE CONTROL ACCOUNT AUTHORIZED
BY THE 2023 BUDGET ACT REGARDING
CLIMATE ACCOUNTABILITY. CHAPTER
LEGISLATION SB 253 AND SB 261,
THE MAYOR VISION REQUEST $8.4
MILLION GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
FUND AND 28 POSITIONS IN 20
2425, 12.3 MILLION GRF AND AN
ADDITIONAL 12 POSITIONS IN 2025,
26 AND 13.9 MILLION FROM TWO
NEWLY ESTABLISHED FUNDS AND AN
ADDITIONAL TWO POSITIONS. THIS
IS HELPFUL. I KNOW WE HAVE SOME
TIME ISSUES HERE WITH SOME
FOLKS, SO MAYBE WE CAN WRAP IT
UP. OKAY I WILL COVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF THEM MUCH MORE QUICKLY
. FOR OFFSHORE WIND, THE MAYOR
VISION INCLUDES A HOLISTIC
OVERALL PACKAGE OF $16 MILLION
THAT REPRESENTS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ATTEMPT AT
PRIORITIZING THE MOST CRITICAL
ACTIVITIES TO GET DONE IN THE
NEXT THREE YEARS FOR OFFSHORE
WIND. SO THAT'S A PROPOSAL
THAT'S BEFORE YOU FOR THE
SCIENCE CENTER. PHASE THREE, THE
MAYOR VISION INCLUDES $2.9
MILLION GENERAL FUND IN THE
FIRST YEAR, 3.7 MILLION ONGOING
FOR FACILITY MAINTENANCE AND
UTILITIES TO COVER THE SCIENCE
CENTERS LEGAL OBLIGATIONS FOR
MAINTAINING THAT FACILITY FOR
CAL FIRE, THERE'S A FIVE
FIREFIGHTER HANDCREW PROPOSAL IN
THE MAYOR VISION THAT INCLUDES
$46.8 MILLION IN THE FIRST YEAR
AND 226 POSITIONS, IT'S PHASED
IN OVER FIVE YEARS WITH THE AND
THE FINAL YEAR AND ONGOING, THE
AMOUNT BECOMES 44.5 MILLION 234
POSITIONS. THESE CREWS HELP TO
PROVIDE VEGETATION MANAGEMENT,
HAZARDOUS FUELS REDUCTION
PROJECTS, AND WILDLAND
SUPPRESSION. AND THE FINAL SORT
OF Kò PROPOSAL IS THE CALIFORNIA
LIFELINE PROGRAM, THE MAYOR
VISION INCLUDES AN AUGMENTATION
OF $31 MILLION FROM THE
UNIVERSAL LIFELINE FUND TO
ACCOUNT FOR AN EXPECTED INCREASE
OF CUSTOMERS THAT WERE
PREVIOUSLY ENROLLED IN THE
EXPIRING FEDERAL AFFORDABLE
CONNECTIVITY PROGRAM, ALONG WITH
ADMINISTERING THE CPU'S USE
FOSTER YOUTH LINE PROGRAM. OKAY,
GREAT. IT'S OUR OVERVIEW. THANK
YOU. LET'S TURN IT OVER TO THE
LEO, PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON.
RACHEL ALERS WITH THE LEO, I
WILL GIVE SOME VERY BRIEF KIND
OF OVERALL BUDGET COMMENT.
CGRTS. AND THEN REGARDING THE
SPECIFIC TOPICS BEFORE YOU. SO
AS WE KNOW, THE STATE CONTINUES
TO FACE A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
BUDGET PROBLEM AND REVENUE
SHORTFALL. WE ALSO HAVE NUMEROUS
PRIORITIES, INCLUDING PURSUING
AMBITIOUS CLIMATE GOALS AND
RESPONDING TO SERIOUS CLIMATE
CHANGE IMPACTS. SO WE VIEW OUR
JOB AS YOUR BUDGET ADVISORS IS
REALLY TRYING TO HELP YOU
CONTINUE TO PURSUE THESE GOALS,
BUT ALSO MEET YOUR
CONSTITUTIONAL OBLIGATION TO
PASS A BALANCED BUDGET. SO
THAT'S THE CONTEXT OF OUR
COMMENTS HERE TODAY AND OUR WORK
WITH YOU OVER THE NEXT FEW WEEKS
, THE COMMENTS REFLECT OUR
PRELIMINARY ASSESSMENT OF THE
MAYOR'S VISION, WHICH OBVIOUSLY
WAS JUST RELEASED. SO WE ARE
STILL WORKING OUR WAY THROUGH
IT. WE PLAN TO PUT OUT OUR FIRST
PUBLICATION BY THE END OF THIS
WEEK ON THE OVERALL BUDGET. OUR
INITIAL COMMENTS, AND THEN
RELEASE OUR MULTIYEAR ASSESSMENT
AT SOME POINT NEXT WEEK. SO
REFLECTING RECENT REVENUE
WEAKNESSES, THE UPDATED
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE REVENUE
ESTIMATES REFLECT A ROUGHLY $10
BILLION REDUCTION COMPARED TO
JANUARY. THAT'S STILL ABOVE OUR
ESTIMATES, BUT IT'S MUCH CLOSER.
SO WE'RE STILL BELOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE BY ROUGHLY
$10 BILLION. BUT IT'S REALLY IN
THE BALLPARK AT THIS POINT. SO
WE THINK THIS IS A REASONABLE
PLACE TO START IN BUILDING YOUR
BUDGET. THESE REVENUE ESTIMATES,
UPON WHICH THE MAY REVISION IS
BUILT. WE DO THINK THERE'S STILL
CONSIDERABLE DOWNSIDE RISK. SO
ONE OF THE KEY QUESTIONS FOR
YOU, AS YOU'RE ADOPTING YOUR
BUDGET IS HOW MUCH DOWNSIDE RISK
ARE YOU COMFORTABLE WITH, AND
KNOWING THAT IF REVENUES DO COME
IN LOWER, THAT WILL REQUIRE SOME
MID-YEAR BUDGET ADJUSTMENTS,
EITHER TURNING TO YOUR RESERVES
OR OR FINDING ADDITIONAL
SOLUTIONS, BUT WE DO THINK IT'S
A REASONABLE STARTING PLACE IN
THE CONTEXT OF THIS SIGNIFICANT
SHORTFALL IN STATE REVENUES.
BASED ON OUR INITIAL REVIEW, WE
DO THINK THERE ARE SEVERAL
POSITIVE FEATURES TO THE OVERALL
ARCHITECTURE OF THE MAY
REVISION, AS WELL AS THE WITHIN
THE RESOURCES BUDGET, OVERALL,
WE FIND THAT THE MAYOR VISION
DOES PUT THE STATE ON BETTER
FISCAL FOOTING OR WOULD PUT THE
STATE ON BETTER FISCAL FOOTING.
IT REDUCES THE RELIANCE ON
RESERVES. SO KIND OF KEEPS MORE
OF THAT TOOL IN YOUR TOOL CHEST,
IF YOU WILL, FOR FUTURE
UNCERTAINTY. WE ALSO PULLS BACK
ON MORE OF THE ONE TIME
SPENDING, WHICH AS WE'VE
DISCUSSED, IS KIND OF A USE IT
OR LOSE IT TOOL. YOU EITHER TAKE
IT BACK OR IT GETS SPENT, AND
THAT ISN'T A TOOL AVAILABLE FOR
YOU IN THE FUTURE. IF YOU'RE
FACING BUDGET PROBLEMS, IT
STARTS TO ADDRESS THE MULTI YEAR
PROBLEM AS WELL. ALTHOUGH THERE
ARE REMAINING DEFICITS IN THE
OUT YEAR FORECAST UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE'S
ESTIMATES. SO OVERALL, WE THINK
THIS APPROACH MAKES IT MORE
LIKELY THAT THE STATE WILL BE
ABLE TO PRESERVE MORE OF ITS
CORE ONGOING PROGRAMS. AND
COMMITMENTS AS, AS THE YEARS GO
THROUGH, ONE OF THE KEY FEATURES
WITHIN THE BUDGET ITEMS THAT YOU
WILL DISCUSS HERE TODAY IS THAT
THE MAY REVISION PROPOSES
CONVERTING MANY OF THE PROPOSALS
THAT IN JANUARY WERE DELAYS TO
FUTURE YEARS, TO INSTEAD BE
REDUCTIONS. IT ALSO REDUCES SOME
OF THAT PLANNED OUT YEAR
SPENDING, AND YOU MAY RECALL
THOSE WERE BOTH RECOMMENDATIONS
WE HAD FOR YOU BACK IN FEBRUARY
THAT IT'S EASIER TO REDUCE
FUNDING THAT HASN'T YET GONE OUT
THE DOOR, THEN FUNDING THAT HAS
AS WELL AS LESS DISRUPTIVE THAN
MAKING CUTS TO ONGOING PROGRAM
CERTAIN YOU COULD REVISIT THAT
IN THE FUTURE IF REVENUES DO
COME IN HIGHER THAN EXPECTED.
BUT WE THINK STARTING WITH A
MORE KIND OF REALISTIC, BASELINE
MAKES SENSE AND PUTS YOU IN A
BETTER POSITION TO ADDRESS YOUR
OUTYEAR BUDGET SITUATION, THERE
ARE ALSO, WITHIN THE MAYOR
VISION, SOME ADDITIONAL
REDUCTIONS TO CURRENT YEAR AND
PRIOR YEAR, ONE TIME SPENDING,
AS WE'VE DISCUSSED THAT, THAT
THAT MAKES SENSE TO DO NOW
BECAUSE THAT TOOL WON'T BE
AVAILABLE IN THE FUTURE. BUT
OVERALL, ONE MESSAGE WE WANT TO
REITERATE FOR YOU IS THAT THIS
IS NOT THE ONLY PACKAGE OF
SOLUTIONS AVAILABLE TO YOU. YOU
HAVE OTHER OPTIONS. THE OVERALL
ARCHITECTURE AND FRAMEWORK MAKES
SENSE TO US, BUT IF THERE ARE
SPECIFIC PROGRAMS THAT ARE
PRIORITIES FOR YOU AS A
LEGISLATURE, YOU HAVE OTHER
OPTIONS FOR FINDING SOLUTIONS.
YOU MAY RECALL THAT BACK IN
FEBRUARY, BASED ON INFORMATION
ON SPENDING WE GOT FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION, WE ESTIMATED
THERE WAS ABOUT $1 BILLION IN
UNSPENT FUNDING FROM CURRENT
YEAR AND PRIOR YEAR
APPROPRIATIONS THAT HAD NOT BEEN
KIND OF RETRACTED AT THAT POINT.
NOW, SOME OF THAT IS PART OF THE
MAY REVISION. SOME OF THAT
LIKELY HAS BEEN SPENT NOW, BUT
WE STILL DO THINK THERE ARE
LIKELY QUITE A BIT OF FUNDING
THAT HAS BEEN APPROPRIATED, BUT
NOT YET GONE OUT THE DOOR. WE'RE
WORKING WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
TO TRY AND GET AN UPDATE ON THAT
INFORMATION FOR YOU AS SOON AS
WE CAN, BUT NONE OF THESE WILL
BE EASY. WE NEED TO STIPULATE
THAT. BUT WE DO THINK THAT BASED
ON WHAT YOUR HIGHEST PRIORITIES
ARE, THERE IS A DIFFERENT
PACKAGE OF SOLUTIONS THAT YOU
CAN PURSUE AND STILL MEET THE
OVERALL ARCHITECTURE. SO YOU
COULD CONSIDER ALTERNATIVES
BOTH. IF SOME OF THESE PROPOSALS
DON'T MEET YOUR PRIORITIES, BUT
ALSO IF SOME OF THEM RAISE
SERIOUS CONCERNS FOR YOU. IN OUR
INITIAL REVIEW, FOR EXAMPLE, ONE
OF THE PROPOSALS IN THE OVERALL
BUDGET IS TO REDUCE STATE
OPERATIONS BY 7.95% ACROSS ALL
DEPARTMENTS, WE THINK THIS WOULD
BE VERY CHALLENGING TO ACHIEVE,
AS WELL AS POTENTIALLY VERY
DISRUPTIVE TO PROGRAM DELIVERY.
SO THAT'S AN EXAMPLE OF A TYPE
OF SOLUTION THAT MAY NOT YIELD
THE SAVINGS THAT IS BUILT INTO
THE MAYOR VISION. YOU MAY WANT
TO TAKE A CLOSER LOOK AT TO THE
DEGREE THAT DOESN'T YIELD THE
SOLUTION YOU NEED. YOU WOULD
NEED TO FIND ALTERNATIVES TO
HOLD THE WHOLE PACKAGE TOGETHER
AND THEN FINALLY, ONE OF THE KEY
FACTORS IS, AS THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE PRESENTED IN THE
PACKAGE, IS THIS APPROACH OF
SHIFTING FUNDING FROM THE
GENERAL FUND TO THE GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION FUND, THE STRATEGY
OVERALL HAS A LOT OF MERIT
BECAUSE IN THAT IT CAN ALLOW THE
STATE TO CONTINUE WITH ITS
PLANNED ACTIVITIES WHILE
REDUCING GENERAL FUND
COMMITMENTS. BUT AGAIN, YOU HAVE
OPTIONS HERE AND SELECTING WHAT
ARE YOUR HIGHEST PRIORITY
ACTIVITIES FOR SUSTAINING
WHETHER IT BE FROM GRF OR FROM
THE GENERAL FUND. I THINK OUR
OVERARCHING RECOMMENDATION WOULD
BE LOOK ACROSS THE PROGRAM UMMS
FIGURE OUT WHAT YOUR HIGHEST
PRIORITIES ARE FOR CONTINUING,
AND THEN FIND THE FUNDING SOURCE
THAT MAKES THE MOST SENSE TO DO
THAT. ONE AREA OF CAUTION WILL
RAISE AGAIN, AS WE HAVE EARLIER,
IS THE RELIANCE ON THE GRF FOR
OUT YEARS. THAT'S EVEN MORE
HIGHER MAGNITUDE IN THE MAY
REVISION THAT IT COUNTS ON $1.8
BILLION IN DISCRETIONARY FUNDS
FOR EACH OF THE NEXT THREE YEARS
AFTER THE BUDGET YEAR, THIS HAS
BEEN A HISTORICALLY SOMEWHAT
VOLATILE FUNDING SOURCE,
ESPECIALLY AS WE GET CLOSER TO
THE STATUTORY SUNSET DATE OF THE
PROGRAM. SO NOT ONLY ARE WE
UNCERTAIN ABOUT HOW MUCH REVENUE
WE WILL HAVE AVAILABLE FROM GRF
A FEW YEARS FROM NOW, WE'RE ALSO
UNCERTAIN WHAT YOUR HIGHEST
PRIORITIES WILL BE, OR WHAT THE
STATE'S HIGHEST PRIORITIES WILL
BE. SO WE WOULD EXERCISE CAUTION
IN COMMITTING SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNTS OF OUTYEAR GQF, AT THIS
POINT, UNTIL WE KNOW MORE ABOUT
WHAT THE STATE'S PRIORITIES WILL
BE AS WELL AS WHAT THE REVENUES
ARE. AND WITH THAT, MR. CHAIR,
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU. I'D LIKE TO OFFER THE
FIRST QUESTION TO SENATOR ALLEN.
I KNOW HE'S GOT SOME. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. REALLY APPRECIATE ALL
THE PRESENTATION. AND THERE'S SO
MANY SO MUCH TO ABSORB. WE HAD A
GOOD BRIEFING IN CAUCUS
YESTERDAY, BUT, YOU KNOW, I
THINK IT CONTINUES TO BE A
CONCERN, THE NUMBER OF CUTS THAT
HAVE BEEN MADE IN THIS, IN THIS
SUB AREA. BUT I ALSO RECOGNIZE
THE VERY DIFFICULTIES OF OUR OF
OUR BROADER BUDGET, I WANTED TO
ASK JUST ONE VERY PARTICULAR
QUESTION ABOUT THE HABITAT
KANSEN CONSERVATION FUND, I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU'RE THE RIGHT
FOLKS OR SOMEONE ELSE HERE, BUT,
I KNOW IT'S BEEN PROPOSED TO
IT'S BEEN SET FOR ELIMINATION.
IT WAS VOTED IT WAS, APPROVED BY
VOTER APPROVAL. IT WAS CREATED
BY VOTER APPROVAL BACK IN 1990,
THERE HAD BEEN AN AGREEMENT MADE
, YOU KNOW, I THINK EARLY IN MY
TIME IN THE SENATE WHEN THE
GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE
AGREED TO EXTEND THE ANNUAL
ANNUAL GENERAL GENERAL FUND
TRANSFER TO THE HABITAT
CONSERVATION FUND AT LEAST UNTIL
2030. AND SO JUST WANTED TO, GET
A BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF, YOU
KNOW, THE THOUGHT PROCESS AS TO
WHY VÌ, I MEAN, UNDERSTANDING
THAT THERE'S A MASSIVE, YOU
KNOW, SET OF FINANCIAL
CHALLENGES. BUT OF COURSE, A LOT
OF THINGS ARE NOT GETTING
ELIMINATED, YOU KNOW, WHAT'S THE
THOUGHT PROCESS OF THIS BEING,
NOT MAINTAINED AS A PRIORITY,
PARTICULARLY GIVEN THE FACT THAT
WE'RE ABOUT TO, YOU KNOW, TO
LIST SEVERAL SPECIES AS
ENDANGERED. SO LET ME THROW THAT
OUT THERE. TO START WITH. YEAH.
AGUILAR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
SO, YOU KNOW, JUST KIND OF
ACKNOWLEDGMENT, THERE ARE MANY
REALLY TOUGH CUTS IN THIS
BUDGET. AND THIS IS DEFINITELY
ONE OF THOSE, TOUGH, TOUGH
REDUCTIONS. THERE IS AN ONGOING
BUDGET DEFICIT. YOU KNOW, I KNOW
OUR BUDGET SPECIFICALLY SOLVES
BUDGET YEAR AND BUDGET YEAR ONE,
BUT WE'RE ALSO TRYING TO SOLVE
THE, YOU KNOW, AS MUCH AS WE CAN
IN TERMS OF SOME OF THE
ADDITIONAL OUT YEARS. SO THIS IS
ONE OF THOSE THAT DOES PROVIDE,
ALSO, YOU KNOW, OTHER OUTYEAR
RELIEF, WITH THAT REDUCTION, BUT
ACKNOWLEDGING, YOU KNOW, THIS
HAS BEEN A, AN IMPORTANT PROGRAM
THAT HAS YIELDED A LOT OF
BENEFITS SINCE IT BEGAN, AND SO
IT'S REALLY JUST, YOU KNOW, A
CUT THAT IS BASED OFF OF THE
CURRENT FISCAL CONDITION, BUT WE
ARE, OF COURSE, YOU KNOW, OPEN
TO HAVING ONGOING CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND ALSO
HEAR OTHER POTENTIAL
ALTERNATIVES. THE LAST THING
I'LL NOTE IS THAT THE PIECE THAT
IS REDUCED IS THE GENERAL FUND
TRANSFER. BUT THE PROP 99 WILL
STILL GET TRANSFERRED INTO THE
FUND. SO THERE WILL STILL BE
FUNDING THAT GO INTO HABITAT
CONSERVATION FUND. IT WON'T BE,
YOU KNOW, THE 30 MILLION THAT
GOES IN NOW. BUT THERE WILL
STILL BE SOME AMOUNT THAT GETS
TRANSFERRED EVERY YEAR FROM THE
PROP 99 ALLOCATION THAT GOES
INTO THE FUND. OKAY. ONE OF THE
QUESTION THAT'S COME UP IS JUST
THE, EXTENT TO WHICH THIS MIGHT
REQUIRE A HIGHER THRESHOLD VOTE,
LIKE A 4/5 VOTE, GIVEN THE FACT
THAT IT AMENDS AN EXISTING
PROPOSITION IN A WAY THAT WASN'T
EXPRESSLY PERMITTED BY THE
STATUTORY LANGUAGE, AND I THINK
THAT IT'S LIKE A FOURTH OR FIFTH
THRESHOLD. SO COULD YOU COULD
YOU GIVE US YOUR, WHERE WE'RE
THINKING ON THAT? THAT IS ALSO
OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT THE 4/5
THAT'S 32 IN THE SENATE. WELL
ALL RIGHT. GOSH. OKAY. YOU'RE
THERE. WELL IF EVERYONE
SUPPORTS, WHERE ARE YOU ON THIS
ONE, MR. DOOLEY? YEAH, I HAVE
SOME POWER. ALL RIGHT, ALL
RIGHT, ALL RIGHT. WELL LET ME
THANK THANK YOU, THANK YOU. I'LL
HAVE SOME MORE QUESTIONS LATER.
PROBABLY WHILE WE'RE ON THAT
TOPIC, I'LL ASK A FEW MORE
MYSELF, AND THEN I'LL GIVE. I
HAVE A LOT TO, TO, QUESTIONS TO
ASK, BUT I'LL GIVE MY COLLEAGUES
SOME OPPORTUNITIES AS WELL, THE,
THE, THE FREEZES TO THE GRANTS
THAT WOULD BE AWARDED AT THE MAY
23RD MEETING. THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD HAS PUBLICLY
NOTICED FOR WEEKS, SOME OF THESE
ARE VERY COMPLICATED. GRANT
LANDOWNER THAT TERMS OF HAVE
BEEN NEGOTIATED AND, YOU'VE GOT
EXPIRATION DATES COMING UP.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT MILLIONS OF
MATCHING FUNDS. AND AS YOU'VE
HEARD IN THIS COMMITTEE BEFORE,
A GREAT CONCERN ABOUT THE FREEZE
THAT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAS
PLACED ON SPENDING, WHICH WOULD
IMPACT ALL OF THESE PROGRAMS. SO
WHAT WHAT IS THE PLAN? CAN WE
RELEASE SOME OF THOSE DOLLARS?
AND, IS THAT FREEZE GOING TO
HAVE TO APPLY HERE? YES, I THINK
FIRST I'LL START OFF BY NOTING
IS THE FREEZE WAS ENACTED IN THE
EARLY ACTION. SO IT'S APPROVED
BY THE LEGISLATURE IN EARLY
ACTION. AND THE CONDITIONS OF
THE FREEZE WERE ALSO IN EARLY
ACTION APPROVED BY THE
LEGISLATURE, AND SO SPECIFICALLY
TO, THE MAY WCB BOARD MEETING
FOR THE GENERAL FUND THAT
APPLIES TO THE FREEZE, THE
APPROACH IS THAT THOSE WILL BE
CONDITIONALLY AWARDED, BUT THEY
WOULDN'T BE ENCUMBERED UNTIL
AFTER THE BUDGET IS ENACTED.
THAT WAY. YOU KNOW, WE KIND OF
MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE
POTENTIAL OPTIONS STILL ON THE
TABLE, WHICH WAS THE GOAL OF THE
FREEZE, WHICH WAS ENACTED IN THE
EARLY ACTION BUDGET BILL. OKAY.
SO CONDITIONALLY ADOPTED IS THE
PLAN. AND THEN FUNDED AFTER THE
BUDGET GETS SIGNED. IF IT
DOESN'T GET REDUCED AS A
SOLUTION. YES. YEAH. OKAY. JOSH,
JUST REAL QUICK. YOU SO SORRY.
YOU MENTIONED SOMETHING ABOUT
TRANSFERRING FROM PROP 99
MONIES. IS THAT CAN YOU TELL US
JUST A QUICK QUESTION ABOUT HOW
MUCH GETS TRANSFERRED UNDER THE
PLAN. SO IT VARIES ANNUALLY
BASICALLY BASED OFF OF TOBACCO
TAX REVENUE. YEAH. BUT YOU KNOW,
IT'S RIGHT. YEAH. IT HAS IT HAS
GONE UP AND DOWN I THINK RIGHT
NOW IT'S CLOSE TO, YOU KNOW, TEN
ISH MILLION. AND SO THE GENERAL
FUND SIDE IS ABOUT 20 WHICH GETS
TO THE 30. SO IT KIND OF HOVERS
BETWEEN LIKE NINE AND 11. BUT
RIGHT NOW IT'S LIKE AT TEN.
OKAY. THANK YOU. SENATOR
BLAKESPEAR YEAH, IT'S ON THE
SAME TOPIC, YEAH. SO I WANTED TO
OFFER MY COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF
MY COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE JUST
BROUGHT THIS UP. AND JUST SO
THAT EVERYBODY IS CLEAR WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT, IT'S ISSUE
NUMBER SEVEN WITH THE TITLE OF
HABITAT CONSERVATION FUND,
GENERAL FUND TRANSFER SUNSET. SO
IT REVERTS 45 MILLION IN THE
YEAR 2023 TO 24, AND THEN 20
MILLION ONGOING FOR THE NEXT
FOUR YEARS, AND I THINK IT'S
JUST IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER HOW
VITAL THIS PROGRAM IS. WE'VE
CONSERVED MORE THAN A MILLION
ACRES USING THIS PROGRAM, AND,
IT WAS CREATED IN 1990 BY THE
VOTERS, AND THEN IT WAS EXTENDED
OUT TO 2030 INTENTIONALLY. AND
IT WAS ALSO, IT'S IMPORTANT TO
NOTE JUST THE IMPORTANCE OF
THIS. IT WAS ACTUALLY OUR
CURRENT GOVERNOR'S FATHER WHO
LED A MOUNTAIN LION FOUNDATION,
THAT WAS A PRIMARY PROPONENT OF
THE BALLOT MEASURE IN 1990. AND
WE'RE JUST ON THE VERGE OF
HAVING THE STATE LIST MOUNTAIN
LIONS AS ENDANGERED ACROSS A
WIDE SWATH OF THE STATE. SO YOU
KNOW, THE HISTORIC PERSPECTIVE
OF THIS AND THE CURRENT
IMPORTANCE OF IT. AND THEN I'LL
JUST ALSO POINT TO A PRESS
RELEASE THAT IS LESS THAN A
MONTH OLD FROM THE OFFICE OF
GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM SAYING
WITH HISTORIC TARGETS,
CALIFORNIA WILL USE MILLIONS OF
ACRES OF LAND TO FIGHT THE
CLIMATE CRISIS. AND THEN TALKING
ABOUT IN THIS PRESS RELEASE THAT
THE STATE HAS UNVEILED 81
TARGETS FOR NATURE BASED
SOLUTIONS THAT WILL HELP
CALIFORNIA ACHIEVE ITS WORLD
LEADING CLIMATE GOALS, INCLUDING
REACHING CARBON NEUTRALITY BY
2045, SO, YOU KNOW, HABITAT
CONSERVATION IS JUST SO CRITICAL
FOR ALL OF OUR STATE GOALS. AND
AND I'M HIGHLY CONCERNED ABOUT
THIS BEING ESSENTIALLY NEARLY
ZEROED OUT. SO I WANT TO
AFFILIATE MY COMMENTS WITH MY
COLLEAGUES WHO'VE ALREADY SAID
THAT. AND JUST MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE THINKING ABOUT THIS
PARTICULAR PROGRAM IN A CONTEXT
OF BROADER CONTEXT OF IT'S NOT
JUST PRESERVING HABITAT FOR
MOUNTAIN LIONS, WHICH IS VERY
IMPORTANT, BUT IT'S ALSO THESE
THIS ENTIRE COMMITTEE'S FOCUS ON
ON OUR CLIMATE GOALS AND OUR
CARBON REDUCTION GOALS, THE
NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS ARE SO
IMPORTANT, AND WE JUST NEED TO
NOT LOSE SIGHT OF THAT. SO THOSE
ARE MY COMMENTS. CHAIR, THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU, SENATOR
DARLING. SO I JUST WILL REAL
QUICK TOUCH ON THAT SINCE
EVERYBODY ELSE HAS TALKED ABOUT
IT. I SIT ON THE SIERRA NEVADA
CONSERVANCY BOARD FOR SEVEN
YEARS. NOT ONLY IS THE THEIR
PARTNERS WITH THOSE FUNDS FLOW
THROUGH THOSE CONSERVANCIES, BUT
THEY'RE BUT THE PRIVATE
INVESTMENT TOO THAT DOESN'T GET
CALCULATED INTO THE AMOUNT OF
CONSERVATION WORK THAT GETS DONE
IS PROBABLY, IN MY MIND, EVEN 3
OR 4 TIMES MORE THAN WHAT THE
AMOUNT THE STATE PUTS IN. SO
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION, WHEN WE WHEN WE
LOOK AT THOSE FUNDS. BUT MORE I
WANT TO CHANGE GEARS A LITTLE
BIT HERE FOR A SECOND, IF I
COULD. I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
GRF FUNDS THAT ARE GOING TO BE
BACKFILLING THE GENERAL FUND.
AND SOMETHING THAT I'VE BEEN
VERY, FOCUSED ON OVER THE YEARS
THAT I'VE BEEN HERE IS THE FACT
THAT WE USE THE GRF FUND FOR A
LOT OF THINGS THAT REALLY AREN'T
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS. AND
I'LL GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE. THERE
WAS A I THINK IT WAS A BILL IN
Â QUÊ, A FEW YEARS BACK THAT
TOOK GREENHOUSE GAS MONIES AND
PUT IT TOWARDS WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND THERE WAS A
AND I THINK WE HAD A DEBATE
ABOUT HOW DO YOU GET, REDUCTION
IN CARBON WITH DOING THIS WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WAS PUT OUT
THERE, AND SOMEHOW IT GOT
THROUGH, AND MY FRIENDS IN THE
ENVIRONMENT JUST WALKED AWAY AND
DIDN'T REALLY FOCUS ON THE FACT
THAT IT REALLY DIDN'T HAVE
ANYTHING TO DO WITH GREENHOUSE.
SO ON ON THESE PROPOSALS, I WENT
THROUGH HERE AND WHERE IT SAYS
REDUCTION, ITS REDUCTION AND
WHERE THERE'S A COST SHIFT, IT'S
MORE THAN LIKELY COMING FROM THE
GRF FUND. SO WHAT WHAT'S THE
SMELL TEST TO ARE THESE REALLY
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GASES OR ARE
THESE JUST AN OFFSET TO THE
GENERAL FUND OF PROGRAMS THAT
WE, THAT THE GOVERNOR WANTS TO,
PRIORITIZE? THANK YOU, SENATOR
DAWLEY, FOR THE QUESTION,
CHRISTIAN BELTRAN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SO,
CONSISTENT WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET IN THE FALL AND KIND OF
CARRYING THAT FORWARD TO NOW,
REALLY THE ADMINISTRATION
APPROACH IS REALLY TO KIND OF
USE GRF TO STAY TRUE TO THE
COMMITMENTS THAT WE MADE WITH
THE LEGISLATURE IN THE PAST,
WHETHER IT'S THROUGH CLIMATE
RESILIENCE AND OTHER PURPOSES
AND OTHER CLIMATE FOCUSED
THEMES, IT IS NOT PROHIBITED
THROUGH A FROM A CONSTITUTIONAL
PERSPECTIVE. AND IT'S CONSISTENT
WITH A LOT OF THE STATUTORY,
GOALS THAT ARE SET FORTH FOR GRF
AND THE FUNDS WITHIN GRF, WHICH
IS FOCUSING IN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND OTHER KIND OF
KEY FACTORS OF WHEN WE DECIDE TO
INVEST THESE FUNDS. SO THAT'S
KIND OF LIKE THE OVERALL
APPROACH THAT WE'RE USING AS
PART OF THE MAY REVISION. SO YOU
DIDN'T REALLY DIRECTLY ANSWER MY
QUESTION, THOUGH. I MEAN,
DISADVANTAGE COMMUNITIES. AND I
AGREE WITH I'M NOT I'M NOT, I'M
NOT ATTACKING OR I'M NOT
CRITICIZING THAT THESE AREN'T
WELL INTENTIONED PROGRAMS, BUT
BUT I AM CONCERNED THE FACT THAT
WE ARE SOMEBODY THAT PUMPS A
GALLON OF GAS INTO THEIR CAR AND
IS EXPECTING THE CARBON TO
REDUCE THAT, THE OFFSET IS GOING
TO Þ, YOU KNOW, DRILLING WATER
WELLS AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. THAT'S REALLY NOT
WHAT WAS SOLD TO THE VOTERS
UNDER AB 32. AND THE EXTENSIONS
OF ALL THESE CLIMATE PROGRAMS.
AND UNFORTUNATELY, EVERYBODY
THAT, YOU KNOW, GAS IS $7 A
GALLON IN SOME PLACES IN
CALIFORNIA, AND THEY'RE PAYING
FOR STUFF THAT IS NOT REDUCING,
NOT NOT, FOCUSED. SO ARE THESE
GOING TO EVERY I LOOK THROUGH.
AND I WAS QUESTIONING SOME OF
THEM AND MAYBE I SHOULD WENT
THROUGH AND HIGHLIGHTED THEM.
BUT I MEAN, HOW ARE YOU HOW ARE
YOU MAKING SURE THAT THEY MEET
THAT CLIMATE GOAL THAT WE'RE
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO MEET AND
NOT JUST COST SHIFTING FROM THE
GENERAL FUND BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE MONEY IN THE GENERAL FUND
RIGHT NOW. SO JUST TO KIND OF
REEMPHASIZE, I THINK A COUPLE OF
POINTS, FIRST AND FOREMOST, YOU
KNOW, WE'RE WE'RE REALLY FACED
WITH A TOUGH BUDGET DECISION.
AND SO A BUDGET CLIMATE, EXCUSE
ME. AND HAVING SAID THAT, THE
GRF DISCRETIONARY POT OF MONEY
HAS BEEN USED IN MANY
CIRCUMSTANCES IN PREVIOUS BUDGET
CYCLES WHERE WE ARE FACED WITH
DIFFICULT BUDGET DECISIONS TO
FUND OTHER CLIMATE FOCUSED
PROGRAMS. AND HAVING SAID THAT,
WITH THE PRECEDENT SET IN PLACE
FROM THE PREVIOUS BUDGET ACTS,
THE ADMINISTRATION FELT IT WAS
APPROPRIATE TO CONTINUE TO LOOK
AT CERTAIN PROGRAMS ACROSS THE
CLIMATE SPECTRUM TO SEE IF WE
COULD FUND IT FROM THE GRF. NOW,
WHETHER OR NOT IT REDUCES GRF,
GREENHOUSE GAS DIRECTLY. YOU
KNOW, THAT IS ANOTHER QUESTION
THAT IS COMING UP IN MANY
CONVERSATIONS AND IS COMPLETELY
UNDERSTOOD AND HEARD. HOWEVER,
GIVEN THE PRECEDENT THAT HAS
BEEN SET AND GIVEN THE CURRENT
BUDGET CLIMATE THAT WE'RE FACED
WITH, WE FELT THAT THIS WAS AN
APPROPRIATE APPROACH FOR THE MAY
REVISION. THANK YOU. I'LL TAKE A
TACK ON THAT. AND I MENTIONED
THIS AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
HEARING AS WELL, WE SEE THAT
TRANSIT IS TAKING UP A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF THE GRF.
THE MAYOR'S VISION INCLUDES $1.3
BILLION SHIFT TO GRF FOR THE
TRANSIT PROGRAMS. SO THAT'S IN
ADDITION TO THE, CONTINUOUS AND
DISCRETIONARY SPENDING FOR HIGH
SPEED RAIL, WHICH IS FUNDED AT
$1 BILLION FOR THE BUDGET YEAR,
AND THE CIP, WHICH FUNDED 400
MILLION FOR THE BUDGET YEAR. SO
I JUST WONDERED, WHY DID THE
ADMINISTRATION NOT PROPOSE USING
OTHER SPECIAL FUNDS IN
TRANSPORTATION TO BACKFILL
TRANSIT PROGRAMS RATHER THAN GRF
, I'LL START WITH A FEW COMMENTS
, CHAIR BECKER, AND THEN I'LL
TURN IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE IF
THEY WOULD LIKE TO ADD ANY
CONTEXT. JUST A QUICK COMMENT.
RATHER, YOU KNOW, WE REALLY
AREN'T THE EXPERTS IN TERMS OF
THE TRANSPORTATION SIDE OF OUR
SHOP. AND SO TO THE EXTENT THAT
THERE'S OTHER FUNDING SOURCES IN
THE TRANSPORTATION REALM THAT
ARE ELIGIBLE TO FUND THESE
PARTICULAR PROGRAMS, WE WOULD
HAVE TO DEFER THE QUESTIONS TO
THEM, HOWEVER, THESE
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS HAVE
HISTORICALLY BEEN, FUNDED
PREVIOUSLY BY BY, GRF, SUCH AS
TRACK AND OTHER PARTICULAR
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS. AND SO
WE FELT THAT IT WAS FIT TO
CONTINUE TO KIND OF PLUS UP
THOSE PROGRAMS UTILIZING GRF,
FUNDS TO THE BEST WE CAN IN
ORDER TO KIND OF HELP OFFSET THE
GENERAL FUND PRESSURE. YEAH.
I'LL JUST ADD, YOU KNOW, I KNOW
TRANSIT HURT IN DIFFERENT
BUDGET. SUBCOMMITTEE ON THE
SENATE SIDE. I THINK THEY HEARD
THAT THIS MORNING AND THEY
ATTENDED THAT HEARING. SO WE
DIDN'T HAVE OUR TRANSIT TEAM
COME TO THIS HEARING, BUT WE
COULD DEFINITELY FOLLOW UP IF
THERE'S KIND OF ANY QUESTION,
FROM OUR TRANSIT SIDE. SO MY
RIGHT, THOUGH, JUST TO LEVEL SET
ON THE NUMBERS THAT THAT WOULD
BE $2.7 BILLION FOR TRANSIT IN
GRF. ARE YOU TALKING ACROSS THE
MULTIYEAR CHAIR, BECKER, YES. IS
THAT THE COST OF TWO YEARS?
BASICALLY, I THINK THE 1.3. WELL
HAVE YOU BEEN MORE THAN THAT
BECAUSE THE CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATION IS A. YEAH. SO
THAT'S SO I GUESS, YEAH, ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS, BECAUSE IT'S
ALREADY 1.4 BILLION ON AN ANNUAL
BASIS. AND SO THIS IS AN
ADDITIONAL 1.3 BILLION OVER TWO
YEARS. IS THAT RIGHT? THAT IS
OUR UNDERSTANDING. BUT WE CAN
DEFINITELY FOLLOW UP AND JUST
VERIFY AND VALIDATE THAT WITH
YOUR STAFF IF YOU'D LIKE. YEAH
SO IT'S STILL WORK OUT TO, YOU
KNOW, OVER 2 BILLION THE NEXT
TWO YEARS. CORRECT ON TRANSIT
PROGRAMS. OKAY. YEAH WE'LL BE
GOOD TO FOLLOW UP AND SEE, YOU
KNOW, WHEN YOU SYNC UP WITH THE
TRANSIT FOLKS, IF THERE'S OTHER
FUNDS AVAILABLE, NOT GRF FOR
THAT, THE MAY REVISION CUTS THE
EQUITABLE BUILDING PROGRAM BY
139 MILLION. HOW WILL THIS CUT
IMPACT THE AMOUNT OF PROJECTS
AND HOUSEHOLDS SERVED? WE'RE
GOING TO DO SOME MUSICAL CHAIRS
AND LET OUR ENERGY TEAM COME UP
AND ANSWER THAT SPECIFIC PROGRAM
QUESTION FOR YOU. ON THAT, WHILE
THEY'RE COMING UP, WE DO HAVE A
GOAL OF 3 MILLION CLIMATE
FRIENDLY HOMES BY 2030 AND 7
MILLION BY 2035, AS WELL AS 6
MILLION HEAT PUMPS DEPLOYED BY
2030. WE. ARE WITH THE HEAT
PUMP, YOU DO GET AIR
CONDITIONING AS WELL AS I NOW
HAVE MY HOME. SO THIS IS MY
ADVERTISEMENT FOR WHILE WE'RE
WAITING FOR HEAT PUMPS. OKAY THE
QUESTION WAS SPECIFICALLY AROUND
THE 139 MILLION FOR EQUITABLE
BUILDING TWO CARBONIZATION
PROGRAM, AND HOW WILL THAT
IMPACT THE AMOUNT OF PROJECTS
AND HOUSEHOLDS SERVED? OH, THIS
ONE DOESN'T TURN ON. THANK YOU,
DAMIEN, CHIEF FINANCIAL OFFICER
AT THE ENERGY COMMISSION. THANKS
FOR THE QUESTION. SO THE MAY
REVISION DOES PROPOSE A CHANGE
IN FUNDING FOR THE EQUITABLE
BUILDING DECARB PROGRAM. IT
RETAINS HALF $1 BILLION IN THE
PROGRAM, COMPARED TO THE 922
MILLION AT THE 2223 BUDGET
AGREEMENT, WHICH IS A
CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT, WITH THOSE
FUNDS COMBINED WITH ABOUT $600
MILLION IN FEDERAL FUNDS, THE
COMMISSION WILL BE PUTTING
TOGETHER A STATEWIDE INCENTIVE
PROGRAM AS WELL AS A DIRECT
INSTALL PROGRAM TO SUPPORT
BUILDING DECARB EFFORTS. DO YOU
THINK WE'LL CAN CONTINUE TO BE
ON TRACK TO MEET THESE GOALS,
THE GOALS THAT YOU CITE, IN
TERMS OF THE METRICS, I'D HAVE
TO GET BACK TO YOU ON HOW THE
DOLLARS SHIFT THOSE METRICS, SO
I CAN DO THAT. OKAY. OKAY AND DO
YOU HAVE A SENSE OF, FOR EVERY,
SAY, 100 MILLION, HOW MANY
HOUSEHOLDS WE HOPE TO SERVE OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT, NOT OFF THE
TOP OF MY HEAD, BUT I WILL PUT
THAT IN THERE. OKAY. THAT WOULD
BE, THAT WOULD BE GOOD TO KNOW,
DO YOU WANT TO MENTION UP FRONT?
AND THEN I'LL OPEN UP TO MY
COLLEAGUES AGAIN FOR, FOR A
MOMENT, WHEN, WHEN I THINK WE
SHOULD ALL BE PARTICULARLY
SENSITIVE TO, AREAS WHERE WE MAY
BE LOSING OUT ON FEDERAL FUNDS
IF WE DON'T INVEST HERE. AND I
WANT TO, I GUESS, NOTE A COUPLE
OF AREAS, ONE AREA IS RELATED TO
CARBON REMOVAL, SUCH AS THE $3.5
BILLION FOR REGIONAL DIRECT AIR
CAPTURE HUBS AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL, WE'VE KIND OF WHITTLED
THE CARBON REMOVAL FUNDS DOWN TO
20 MILLION. SO WILL THAT BE
SUFFICIENT TO LEVERAGE THESE
FEDERAL FUNDS AND, WILL ARE WE
AT RISK CERTAINLY OF LOSING OUT
ON, ON, ON FEDERAL FUNDS, FOR
CARBON REMOVAL INNOVATION. YEAH,
I'LL TAKE THAT ONE AGAIN. SO THE
CARBON REMOVAL INNOVATION
SUPPORT PROGRAM IS PROJECTED IS
NOW BUDGETED TO RECEIVE $20
MILLION IN 2025, 26, TO THE
EXTENT THAT THERE'S
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FEDERAL FUNDS
AVAILABLE AT THAT TIME, THE CDC
WOULD LOOK FORWARD TO USING
THOSE DOLLARS TO LEVERAGE
FEDERAL FUNDS RIGHT? THAT'S NOT
THE QUESTION I'M ASKING. THE
QUESTION I'M ASKING IS, DO WE
RISK LOSING BY CUTTING DOWN TO
20 MILLION? FOR EXAMPLE, IF WE
WERE INCREASED, IS THERE
INCREASED FEDERAL FUNDS THAT
WOULD BE AVAILABLE IF WE
INVESTED MORE IN THIS AREA? BUT
THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING FOR
SURE. CERTAINLY GOTCHA. SO THE
QUESTION IS, DOES THE CHANGE IN
FUNDING PUT AT RISK THE STATE'S
ABILITY TO DRAW DOWN FEDERAL
FUNDS? YEAH, I THINK THAT HAS TO
DO A LOT WITH SOME OF THE
TIMING, AT WHICH POINT WHEN THE
DOE WILL MAKE THOSE FUNDS
AVAILABLE, IN SOME CASES, THE
DOE D¯ÚI HAS MOVED QUICKLY. IN
SOME CASES, THE DOE HAS, I
SHOULD SAY DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY
HAS MOVED LESS QUICKLY THAN
PERHAPS WE WOULD HAVE HOPED, AND
SO I THINK THE QUESTION REALLY
HAS TO DO WITH WHEN THOSE
DOLLARS WILL BE AVAILABLE. SOME
OF THOSE ANSWERS ARE AVAILABLE
TO US FROM DOE. AT TIMES THAT WE
WOULD LIKE. AND SOMETIMES THAT
INFORMATION IS FORTHCOMING. SO I
THINK ONE OF THE DIFFICULT
ANSWER IS WE DON'T KNOW YET. AND
PART THAT'S PARTLY BECAUSE OF
INFORMATION THAT HAS YET TO BE
RELEASED BY THE DOE. WELL, I
UNDERSTAND THAT SOMETIMES IT IS
A TIMING ISSUE, BUT IN THIS
CASE, WE DO KNOW THAT THERE'S
THIS PROGRAM, OUT THERE. AND MY
UNDERSTANDING IS IF WE WERE TO
PUT MORE MONEY FORWARD, WE WOULD
BE IN POSITION TO RECEIVE MORE
MONEY. IT'S REALLY A, YOU KNOW,
THIS IS NOT ONE OF THOSE AREAS
WHERE THERE'S A LOT OF,
AMBIGUITY ABOUT THAT, I DON'T
BELIEVE, SO, I GUESS THAT'S
REALLY THE QUESTION IS, YOU KNOW
, DO WE RISK BY MAKING A CUT IN
THAT AREA? DO WE RISK LEVERAGING
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDS? IT
SOUNDS LIKE, YOU KNOW, I WILL
HAVE TO LOOK BACK AT THE
OPPORTUNITIES AVAILABLE RIGHT
NOW, IF THE CADENCE IS SUCH THAT
THE FUNDS THAT ARE PLANNED TO BE
AVAILABLE IN 25, 26 WOULD MEET
THE DOE'S REQUIREMENTS, THEN THE
ANSWER WOULD BE NO. BUT WE'LL
HAVE TO CHECK AND SEE WHEN
EXACTLY THESE FUNDS, THE
SPECIFIC FUNDS YOU'RE REFERRING
TO WOULD BE AVAILABLE. AND WE
CAN GET BACK TO YOU ON THAT ONE.
YEAH. GREAT. AND AGAIN, I THINK
IT'S NOT JUST THE TIMING
SEQUENCE HERE. IT'S THE AMOUNT,
THAT WE'RE PUTTING ON THE TABLE.
WE'RE NOT PUTTING ON THE TABLE
AS THE CASE MIGHT BE WITH THIS,
WITH THIS CUT. SO WE WOULD LIKE
TO CONTINUE TO, TO FOLLOW THAT
ONE. AND, YOU KNOW, HEAR BACK
FROM YOU. BUT THAT'S OUR, OUR
CONCERN. OR CERTAINLY ONE
CONCERN THAT I HAVE ABOUT
PUTTING THAT MONEY AT RISK.
GREAT OTHER STUFF TO GO INTO. MY
COLLEAGUES FOR A MOMENT. AND
SENATOR BLAKESPEAR. YES. THANK
YOU. YES. THANK YOU. I WANTED TO
TALK ABOUT WATER A LITTLE BIT.
I'M. I'M READING THE DREAMT LAND
BY MARK ERICKSON AND, SO WATER
IS MUCH ON MY MIND, AND, AND THE
COMBINATION OF THE DECREASES IN
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET, THE 2020 4TH
JANUARY BUDGET PROPOSAL, AND NOW
THIS MAY REVISION HAS THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSING TO CUT
APPROXIMATELY $2 BILLION FOR
WATER SUPPLY, WATER SUPPLY AND
QUALITY PROJECTS AND PROGRAMS.
AND SO I'M WONDERING YOU KNOW,
WATER IS A TOP PRIORITY FOR THE
STATE ACROSS MANY DIFFERENT,
TYPES OF WATER MANAGEMENT AND I
WANTED TO SEE IF THERE ARE ANY
PROPOSALS, POTENTIALLY FOR A
BOND RELATED TO WATER OR OTHER
THINGS THAT YOU COULD ADD AS,
YOU KNOW, HOW WE'RE GOING TO
DEAL WITH THIS REALLY IMPORTANT
RESOURCE WITH A, A PROPOSAL FOR
THIS $2 BILLION CUT. YES. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SO THE
MAY REVISION DOES NOT INCLUDE
ANY ASSUMPTIONS FOR A BOND,
WE'RE AWARE THAT THERE'S VARIOUS
BONDS MOVING FORWARD WITHIN THE
LEGISLATURE, BUT THE MAY
REVISION DOES NOT INCLUDE ANY
ANY ASSUMPTIONS RELATED TO THAT.
OR I WILL NOTE, THOUGH, IN TERMS
OF WATER, FROM THE 21 AND 2022
MULTI-YEAR PACKAGES, WE HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO PRESERVE 76% OF
THAT. AND THAT'S, $6.6 BILLION.
AND SO THAT IS VERY SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT INVESTMENT JUST STARTING
FROM 2021 TO NOW, 2024. SO EVEN
WITH THESE REDUCTIONS, THIS IS A
PRETTY HISTORIC LEVEL OF, OF
INVESTMENT THAT WE STILL HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO MAINTAIN. AND ONE
OF THE AREAS Tê THAT WE'VE
ACTUALLY DONE MORE MONEY IN IS
WATER HAS, IN ADDITION TO $6.6
BILLION. THAT HAS BEEN FLOOD
INVESTMENT THAT WERE PUT
TOGETHER IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET.
NEW FLOOD INVESTMENTS IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET, ACKNOWLEDGING,
YOU KNOW, PUBLIC SAFETY ELEMENTS
TO IT. AND SO WATER HAS ACTUALLY
BEEN ONE OF THE AREAS WHERE
THERE'S ACTUALLY BEEN NEW MONEY
WHEN WE'RE MAKING REDUCTIONS AND
A LOT OF OTHER AREAS. AND SO WE
ACKNOWLEDGE WATER IS AND REMAINS
A PRIORITY, WHICH IS WHY WE
PROTECTED A LOT. AND THEN WE'VE
ALSO HAVE HAD NEW INVESTMENTS IN
ADDITION TO THESE 6 BILLION THAT
WE'VE INVESTED. OKAY. THANK YOU.
WELL, CERTAINLY ECHO IF THESE
CUTS DO GO THROUGH AND I
UNDERSTAND WE PUT A LOT OF MONEY
OUT THERE. BUT THAT'S ALSO
BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF NEED.
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION WOULD
SUPPORT A CLIMATE BOND WHICH
WOULD INCLUDE SOME OF THESE,
AREAS THAT WOULD CERTAINLY BE MY
HOPE. I KNOW YOU CAN'T
PERSONALLY COMMIT TO THAT AT THE
MOMENT, BUT THAT'S CERTAINLY OUR
HOPE FOR THE ADMINISTRATION. IN
LIEU OF SOME OF THESE PROJECTS,
BECAUSE WE KNOW IT'S POSSIBLE
RIGHT THERE IS A BOND BEING
DISCUSSED AT THIS TIME. I WILL
ASK YOU ABOUT, THE SAFE DRINKING
WATER. I WANT TO STAND AGAIN,
THE GRF IMPLICATIONS HERE
BECAUSE THE MAY REVISION SHIFTS
352 MILLION. AGAIN, VERY
IMPORTANT CAUSE DRINKING WATER
NOT GENERALLY TIED TO GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTIONS, BUT, 352 MILLION
TO GRF. IS THAT IN ADDITION TO
THE 130 MILLION ALREADY
APPROPRIATED ON AN ANNUAL YEAR
FOR, AND CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATIONS FOR SAFE DRINKING
WATER? PLANNING DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE, THE $130 MILLION FROM
GRF TO THE SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER FUND FOR THE
SAFER PROGRAM ARE SEPARATE FROM
THIS GENERAL FUND SHIFT, OF
GENERAL FUNDS TO THE GRF, WE ARE
SCHEDULING OR PROPOSING $322.5
MILLION OF GRF IN 2024, 25, AND
$30 MILLION FOR GRF IN 20 2526.
AND THAT COMES FROM $152.5
MILLION GENERAL FUND IN 20 2324.
THAT AMOUNT IS FULLY SHIFTED TO
GRF IN 2024 AND 25, AND THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSED $200
MILLION GENERAL FUND, IN 20
2425. THAT HAS BEEN $170 MILLION
OF THAT HAS BEEN SHIFTED TO GRF
IN THE SAME YEAR, WITH 30
MILLION, SHIFTED TO GRF IN 2025,
26. SO WHAT HOW ARE THE TYPES OF
PROJECTS GOING TO DIFFER, IN
THAT 352 MILLION VERSUS THE 130
MILLION CONTINUES
APPROPRIATIONS? OH, GO AHEAD, GO
AHEAD. YOU HAVE TO TAP THERE WE
GO. HI, JOE KURKOWSKI, STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD. I
HEAD UP OUR DIVISION OF
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE. SO
BASICALLY, WE WOULD FOLLOW THE
PRIORITIES THAT THE LEGISLATURE
OUTLINED WITH THE ORIGINAL
GENERAL FUND APPROPRIATIONS. SO
FOR DRINKING WATER IS TO
PRIORITIZE SMALL, DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. SO WE WOULD
CONTINUE TO DO THAT. AND RIGHT
NOW, WE HAVE ABOUT $1 BILLION OR
SO OF PENDING, APPLICATIONS SO
CLOSE TO 300 OR SO PROJECTS FROM
SMALL DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
SO WE'D FUND THOSE IN A PRIORITY
ORDER. AND THEN ON THE
WASTEWATER SIDE, THE PRIORITY,
THE PRIORITIES FOR, SEPTIC TO
SEWER PROJECTS. AND THOSE ARE
USUALLY VERY BIG DOLLAR
PROJECTS. SO WE WOULD CONTINUE
TO PRIORITIZE THOSE ON THE SMALL
COMMUNITY WASTEWATER SIDE. THERE
ARE ABOUT A $1.8 BILLION IN
PENDING, FUNDING APPLICATIONS
FROM SMALL COMMUNITIES,
PRIMARILY OUR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES, DEFINE IS THAT
INCLUDE RURAL COMMUNITIES AS
WELL? YEAH. SO DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES HAVE A MEDIAN
HOUSEHOLD INCOME OF 80% OR LESS
THAN THE STATEWIDE MEDIAN
HOUSEHOLD INCOME. SO I THINK
THAT'S PROBABLY AROUND $60,000
OR SO. NOW. SENATE DISTRICT ONE.
YES. OKAY. WELL, WE'LL HAVE TO
OBVIOUSLY COME BACK TO THAT.
AND, AND, CERTAINLY VERY WORTHY
PROJECT THAT HAS BEEN SUPPORTED
BY THE LEGISLATURE. I GUESS THE
QUESTION IS REALLY, DOES IT
BELONG IN THE GRF FUND OR REALLY
ELSEWHERE, BUT CERTAINLY
IMPORTANT. OKAY DID HAVE A
QUESTION AROUND, THE ZEV PACKAGE
IN THIS COMMUNITY FROM CARB OR
CC OR THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
SO ONE AREA THAT, YOU KNOW,
CERTAINLY COULD UNDERSTAND,
SHIFTING SOME OF THE ZEV PACKAGE
INTO GRF AS, AS TRANSPORTATION
IS THE LEADING SOURCE OF
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS IN OUR,
IN OUR STATE, UNFORTUNATELY,
THOSE PROGRAMS ARE NOT
PRIORITIZED FOR 24, 25 IS MY
UNDERSTANDING. SO THEY'RE KIND
OF SHIFTED EVEN INTO GRF BUT OUT
OF THE BUDGET YEAR. SO HOW CAN
WE NOT PRIORITIZING THOSE
PROJECTS TO, TO MEET OUR, OUR
GOALS, BRANDON MAYOR, DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE I JUST WAS WONDERING
IF YOU COULD, SPECIFY WHICH ONES
YOU'RE LOOKING AT IN PARTICULAR.
YEAH, I THINK BROADLY, I CAN GO
BACK AND LOOK AT THE DETAIL, BUT
I THINK IT'S BROADLY THE ZEV
PROGRAM RAIMES ARE SHIFTED, OUT
OF 2425. SO CHAIR BECKER, I
BELIEVE YOU'RE REFERRING TO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ORIGINAL
PROPOSAL TO MOVE 600 MILLION
FROM BUDGET YEAR INTO THE OUT
YEARS. AND ESSENTIALLY THE
PURPOSE OF THAT SHIFT WAS TO
OPEN UP 600 MILLION, ROUGHLY OF
AVAILABLE DISCRETIONARY FUNDS TO
INVEST IN OTHER PROGRAMS. AND
THEN IN ADDITION TO THAT,
THERE'S SOME OTHER, FUNDS THAT
ARE BEING PROPOSED AS BEING
REDUCED FOR THE CEC PROGRAMS. SO
WE'RE GOING FROM THAT 10 BILLION
NUMBER TO THE 9.6 BILLION
NUMBER. SO THOSE, PARTICULAR
PROGRAMS ARE BEING PROPOSED AS
REDUCTIONS, ESSENTIALLY DUE TO
THE FACT THAT THOSE ARE THE ONLY
PROGRAMS IN THE WORLD THAT ARE
STILL, HAVE SOME KIND OF GENERAL
FUND BALANCE. OTHER PREVIOUS
PROGRAMS AT THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD, SPECIFICALLY SPECIFIC TO
THE VEHICLE INCENTIVE PROGRAMS,
ARE FUNDED NOW BY GQF. AND SO,
THEREFORE, AS PART OF THE
OVERALL BUDGET KIND OF APPROACH
OF TRYING TO FIND GENERAL FUND
SOLUTIONS AND SAVINGS, WE
FOCUSED ON REDUCING THOSE CTC
PROGRAMS IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE
THAT GOAL. BUT I'M LOOKING AT
ZEV PROGRAMS, SHIFTED 385
MILLION TO 25, 26, 299 MILLION
2627, 387 TO 2728. RIGHT? RIGHT.
BUT WE'RE NOT PRIORITIZING FOR
2425. CORRECT. WE TRY TO AGAIN,
I THINK, PRIORITIZE,
DIVERSIFYING THE AMOUNT OF
AVAILABLE RESOURCES FOR OTHER
PROGRAMS AND MAINTAINING
COMMITMENTS. SO MAYBE MY
COLLEAGUE JOINING ME AT THE
TABLE CAN ALSO PROVIDE SOME
ADDITIONAL CONTEXT. YEAH HELLO,
STEVE WELLS, DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. AND I CAN JUST ADD TO
THAT THE REASON THERE'S SO MUCH
THAT'S SHIFTED OUT OF 2425 IS
THAT FOR MOST OF THE ZEV
PROGRAMS, THEY'RE WORKING WITH A
PRETTY LARGE BALANCE THAT WAS
APPROPRIATED IN 2223 AND 2324.
SO WE SAW THAT AS AN OPPORTUNITY
AS WE, YOU KNOW, AS THOSE
BALANCES ARE BEING YOU KNOW,
THEY'VE BEEN IN, IN MANY CASES
AWARDED, BUT THEY HAVEN'T
ACTUALLY BEEN LIQUIDATED. SO AS
THOSE BALANCES LIQUIDATE, THAT
CAN GET US THROUGH THE 24, 25
YEAR, OKAY. I HAVE A QUESTION.
SURE SO, THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIRMAN. SO I'M LOOKING AT THE
GENERAL FUND, THOUGH, AND IT'S A
STRAIGHT REDUCTION, FOR THE
FUELING INFRASTRUCTURE GRANTS,
THE EQUITABLE AT HOME CHARGING
THE DRIED TRUCKS. AND IT'S ABOUT
IF YOU TOTAL THOSE UP OUT OF THE
GENERAL FUND, IT'S 300, ABOUT
380 MILLION. RIGHT SO, WHICH I
KNOW WE GOT TO DO WHAT WE GOT TO
DO, BUT ARE THE MANDATES. SO
MOST OF THESE FOLKS THAT ARE
TRYING TO MEET THE CRITERIA IS
THAT CARB HAS BEEN GIVEN THROUGH
EXECUTIVE ORDERS AND THROUGH
FOLLOW UP LEGISLATION. ARE ARE
THEY GOING TO RELAX THOSE
MANDATES DUE TO THE FACT THAT WE
DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES TO MOVE
THE INFRASTRUCTURE SIDE OF IT
INTO PLACE? NO, THAT'S NOT PART
OF THE MAY REVISION TO PROVIDE
ANY KIND OF AUTHORITY OR
STATUTORY CHANGES TO STEP BACK
ON OUR CURRENT COMMITMENTS AND
GOALS. SO JUST FOR THE MEMBERS,
WE'RE BASICALLY SAYING TO, YOU
KNOW, THE BUSINESSES OUT THERE,
HEY, WE'RE NOT GOING TO RELAX
THE REGULATION SIDE OF IT, BUT
WE'RE NOT GOING TO HELP YOU WITH
THE FUNDING SIDE OF IT, WHICH
WAS WHAT THEY HAVE ALWAYS HAD
THE CARROT OUT THERE. NOW YOU'RE
TAKING THE CARRIED AWAY AND THE
STICK IS STILL AVAILABLE, WITH
NO FUNDING. DAVID EVANS, THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. YEAH SO
THE REDUCTIONS THAT YOU'RE
SEEING, SO, FOR INSTANCE, THE
FUELING INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT
PROGRAM, THAT PROGRAM WAS
AWARDED, ON GENERAL FUND AND GRF
IN THE 2023 BUDGET ACT. AND SO,
THE PROPOSAL THAT IS INCLUDED IN
THE MAY REVISION, AS THE GENERAL
FUND DOLLARS WERE BEING
COMMITTED OR AWARDED, WE'RE
SCORING AS A SOLUTION. SO WE'RE
BASICALLY SWAPPING OUT, FUNDS
THAT WERE ALREADY APPROPRIATED
GRF DOLLARS ARE ALREADY THAT
THEY ALREADY HAD. AND SO INSTEAD
OF THEM USING THEIR GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS, THEY WOULD USE THEIR
DUDAREV DOLLARS. AND THEN THAT
WAY WE CAN SCORE A REDUCTION FOR
THE THAT WAY WE CAN APPLY A
GENERAL FUND SOLUTION, SLOW
DOWN. SO OVERALL, THEIR BALANCE
INCLUDED BOTH GENERAL FUND AND
GRF ALREADY. SO BEFORE PRIOR TO
ANY FUND SHIFTS THAT ARE TALKED
ABOUT IN GOVERNOR'S BUDGET OR
MAY REVISE. SO THEY HAD A TOTAL
BALANCE. SOME OF THOSE FUNDS
HAVE NOT YET BEEN COMMITTED. SO
THAT ALLOWED US TO TAKE A
REDUCTION TO THE GENERAL FUND.
AND IN THE CASES WHERE IF THAT
GENERAL FUND, IF THEY HAD
COMMITTED THAT GENERAL FUND,
THEY HAVE GENERAL THEY HAVE
UNCOMMITTED GRF THAT CAN
SUBSTITUTE FOR IT, THE TOTAL
AMOUNT. SO THOSE THE, THE FOUR
PROGRAMS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE ARE ABOUT $2 BILLION.
AND THE COMBINED REDUCTION THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE IS
ABOUT LEAVES ABOUT 85% OF THE
FUNDING STILL AVAILABLE. SO
WHILE IT'S A HAIRCUT, IT'S YOU
KNOW, THERE'S STILL QUITE A
DECENT AMOUNT OF FUNDING LEFT IN
THOSE. RIGHT. I UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU'RE DOING. BASICALLY FUNDS
THAT WEREN'T COMMITTED BUT WERE
PROMISED ARE NOT. AND SO THAT'S
HOW YOU BALANCE IT. I GOT IT,
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY, I SIT
ON THE TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ALL I'M
MAINLY CONCERNED ABOUT THE DRY
TRUCKS AND THE AND THE PORTS
ISSUES. AND THEY'RE COUNTING ON
THIS MONEY TO GET THE
INFRASTRUCTURE PUT IN, NO MATTER
IF IT'S THIS YEAR, NEXT YEAR OR
THE FOLLOWING YEAR, THERE'S A
PLAN PUT IN PLACE TO GET IT
DONE. AND WHEN YOU REDUCE IT
WITH ONGOING BUDGETS, WE AND
THERE'S REGULATORY, PROCESS SET
IN PLACE AS WELL. SO THEY HAVE
TO MEET THESE MANDATES AND SO ON
. AND WE'RE PROMISED FUNDS. SO I
THINK IT'S TO BE HONEST, WE NEED
TO TELL THEM, HEY, IN THE OUT
YEARS WE MIGHT NOT GET THERE. SO
FOR ME AS A SOMEBODY THAT IF I
WAS RUNNING A BUSINESS, I WANT
TO KNOW, WHY AM I WHY AM I STUCK
NOW? AM I GOING TO JUST HAVE TO
EAT IT AT THE END, OR ARE WE
GOING TO DO SOMETHING? AND
THAT'S WHAT I THINK WE NEED TO
BE HONEST ABOUT. WE DON'T EVER
REDUCE REGULATION HERE. WE
CONTINUE TO MARCH ON AND BUT WE
CUT THE FUNDS OR WE PROMISE THE
FUNDS TO GET THERE. SO PEOPLE
GO, OH, I'M IN TO SAVE THE
ENVIRONMENT. AS LONG AS THE, YOU
KNOW, STATE IS HERE TO HELP ME
GET TO WHERE WE NEED TO GO. AND
ALL OF A SUDDEN, THE STATE IS NO
LONGER THERE AND YOU'RE STUCK
STILL WITH THE MANDATE TO REDUCE
YOUR, YOU KNOW, GHG OR WHATEVER
IT IS. AND THERE'S NO FUNDS
AVAILABLE, YOU'RE STUCK. YOU
STILL HAVE THE REQUIREMENT, BUT
YOU DON'T HAVE THE MONEY. SO I
THINK WE NEED TO BE HONEST ABOUT
IT. IN THE OUT YEARS, THE
GENERAL FUND IS NOT
PARTICIPATING, PERIOD. EVEN
THOUGH THIS YEAR IT'S A WASH
BECAUSE THE MONEY HASN'T BEEN
OUT. I KNOW IT DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE. IT DOESN'T MATTER RIGHT
NOW, BUT IT WILL MATTER IN THREE
YEARS WHEN SOMEBODY'S TRYING TO
PUT THESE THINGS TOGETHER. AND I
THINK WE NEED TO BE HONEST WITH
THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE COME TO
THESE COMMITTEES, WHO HAVE BEEN
TOLD, HEY, THE STATE'S HERE,
WE'RE GOING TO LEAD THE WORLD IN
THE ENVIRONMENT AND WE'RE GOING
TO BE YOUR PARTNER. AND NOW,
RIGHT NOW, WE'RE TELLING THEM
BASICALLY WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE
YOUR PARTNER IN THREE YEARS, BUT
WE'RE GOING TO HOLD YOU TO THE
LAW THAT SAYS YOU'RE GOING TO
REDUCE YOUR CARBON FOOTPRINT.
THAT'S WRONG. WE NEED TO FIX
THAT. ALL RIGHT. I HAVE THREE
OTHER TOPICS I WANT TO TOUCH ON.
I'M GOING TO STEP OUT FOR ONE
MOMENT FOR ANOTHER CALL, AND
I'LL HAND IT OVER AT SOME POINT
FOR FULL YOU CAN CONTINUE THAT
CONVERSATION. I DID WANT TO
TOUCH ON THREE, AREAS. ONE IS
JUST TO BACK TO THE FEDERAL FUND
QUESTION. NOW THAT IT'S BEEN A
COUPLE OF MONTHS SINCE WE
DISCUSSED THIS, AND THERE'S
OTHER AREAS NOW BEING CUT WHERE
ARE YOU SEEING, THE GREATEST
POTENTIAL OR FOR FEDERAL FUNDS,
PARTICULARLY IN THE, IN THE
ENERGY AREA FROM ENERGY. OKAY
SO, IRA, IN TERMS OF THE FEDERAL
FUNDING FOR ENERGY SPECIFIC.
YEAH JUST FROM THE INFLATION
REDUCTION ACT OR ANYTHING THAT
MAY HAVE COME, I'M GOING TO TURN
TO MY COLLEAGUES, PROBABLY
BEHIND ME, AND DO SOME MUSICAL
CHAIRS AGAIN. MR. CHAIR.
HELLO AGAIN. DAMIAN WITH THE
ENERGY COMMISSION, THE MAY
REVISION DOES INCLUDE A BCP FOR
$390 MILLION IN FEDERAL
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY FOR SIX
PROGRAMS, AND I'LL LIST THEM
DOWN RIGHT NOW IF THAT'S
PREFERRED. YES, SIR. SO SAY
AGAIN, THIS IS THE LIST OF WHAT
THE REVISION DOES INCLUDE A
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL. FOR $390
MILLION IN FEDERAL FUNDING FOR
CDC, FOR FUNDING THAT WE'VE
RECEIVED THROUGH THE IRA AND
IIJA. SURE. YEAH. SO IT'S A $289
MILLION FOR, HOME ENERGY
PERFORMANCE BASED REBATES. THOSE
ARE REBATES TO HOMEOWNERS, FOR,
WHOLE HOUSE RETROFITS. AND
THAT'S IRA FORMULA FUNDS, $10
MILLION FOR ENERGY EFFICIENCY
TRAINING FOR CONTRACTORS. AND
THOSE ARE IRA FORMULA FUNDS, $17
MILLION TO SUPPORT THE ADOPTION
OF, THE LATEST MODEL ENERGY
BUILDING CODES. THOSE ARE IRA
FORMULA FUNDS, ABOUT $7 MILLION
FOR A REVOLVING LOAN FUND FOR
ENERGY EFFICIENCY. THOSE ARE
IIJA FORMULA FUNDS, ABOUT $5
MILLION FOR AN ENERGY EFFICIENCY
AND CONSERVATION BLOCK GRANT.
EXCUSE ME. THOSE ARE IRA FORMULA
FUNDS AND ABOUT $60 MILLION IN
REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY FOR CDC
TO WORK WITH CALTRANS FOR
UPGRADES OF, ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE FUELING INFRASTRUCTURE.
VERY GOOD. WE'D LOVE TO GET A
COPY OF THAT. THAT'S HELPFUL.
THANK YOU, I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
OFFSHORE. AND BEFORE THAT, I
WANT TO TALK ABOUT BROADBAND
BECAUSE THAT IS ANOTHER AREA
WHERE THERE'S A LOT OF FEDERAL
FUNDING. AND, I FOUND MYSELF
AFTER OUR LAST HEARING ON THIS,
PROBABLY A LITTLE MORE CONFUSED
THAN I WAS AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE HEARING, ABOUT OUR STRATEGY
FOR BROADBAND. SO I WAS HOPING
AND IF WE HAVE FOLKS HERE FROM
THE CPUC DIRECTLY, MAYBE IN
ADDITION TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE, THIS IS JUST, AGAIN, AT
A HIGH LEVEL, JUST TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND, HOW MANY PEOPLE IN
THE STATE DO NOT HAVE BROADBAND
ACCESS TODAY. AND THEN WHEN
WE'VE SPENT THIS $6 BILLION OR
WHATEVER IT IS NOW BETWEEN THE
FEDERAL AND STATE MONEY, HOW
MANY PEOPLE WILL NOT HAVE
BROADBAND AT THE END OF THAT? IT
WAS WORKING FOR DAVID. THERE WE
GO. OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR
BECKER, THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
. THANK YOU, MEMBERS, FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE. RACHEL
PETERSON, EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. I THINK PART OF THE
CHALLENGE WAS ANSWERING YOUR
QUESTION, SENATOR, IS THAT,
DEFINITIONS OF UNSERVED AND
UNDERSERVED DIFFER ACROSS BOTH
STATE AND FEDERAL REGULATIONS
AND LAW, AND SO, THE OTHER PART
AND THE OTHER COMPLICATING
FACTOR IS THAT WE'RE IT'S AN
ITERATIVE, PROGRESSIVE PROCESS.
SO THE INVESTMENTS THAT WE MAKE
VIA FEDERAL FUNDING ACCOUNT,
WHICH ARE COMING THIS YEAR, WILL
TRANSFORM SOME A NUMBER OF
HOUSEHOLDS FROM UNSERVED TO
SERVED. IT WILL ALSO CREATE
NETWORKS THAT WHEREBY OTHER
HOUSEHOLDS CAN GO FROM
UNDERSERVED TO SERVED. THAT WILL
BE AN ENTIRE THAT WILL BE A
SCOPE OF PROGRESS THAT THEN OUR
OTHER FEDERAL PROGRAM, BEAD WILL
ENTER INTO. AND ADDITIONALLY
MOVE HOUSEHOLDS FROM BOTH
UNSERVED AND UNDERSERVED TO
SERVED. SO THERE'S KIND OF A
LARGE TRAJECTORY GOING ON, AND
QUANTIFYING IT IS DIFFICULT, BUT
I AM JOINED BY OUR BROADBAND
DEPUTY HERE, MARIA ELLIS, WHO
KNOWS THE TECHNICAL ELEMENTS OF
UNSERVED, UNDERSERVED AND THE
TRAJECTORY BETTER THAN I DO,
THANK YOU, SENATORS, FOR HAVING
ME HERE TODAY. MARIA ELLIS,
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR BROADBAND AT
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. IN TERMS OF THE
TOTAL, UNSERVED, AS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR PETERSEN MENTIONED,
THERE ARE IT REALLY DEPENDS ON
THE PROGRAM AND HOW YOU ARE
DEFINING IT. EACH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DEFINES HAS A
SPECIFIC DEFINITION FOR WHAT HOW
THEY DETERMINE, AN UNSERVED
LOCATION. AND BASED ON THAT
FEDERAL DEFINITION, THEN, THE
BEAD PROGRAM HAS IDENTIFIED WHAT
WE FEEL IS LOW, BUT IS ROUGHLY
450,000. LET ME REPHRASE THAT.
306 UNSERVED LOCATIONS AND
ANOTHER 154,000 UNDERSERVED
LOCATIONS, 306,000 UNSERVED AND
150,000 UNSERVED, MORE OR LESS.
YES, ROUGHLY SPEAKING. AND SO
THAT'S BY THEIR DEFINITION, AND
THAT DEFINITION INCLUDES A MIX
OF TECHNOLOGY, LATENCY, SPEEDS,
AND SO IT REALLY DEPENDS ON HOW
YOU'RE SLICING AND DICING THAT,
TECHNOLOGY SPEEDS AND LATENCY.
WHEREAS THE FEDERAL FUNDING
ACCOUNT, HAS ALMOST, BY ITS
DEFINITION, WHICH IS WHETHER YOU
HAVE RELIABLE WIRELINE CABLE
TECHNOLOGY, THAT DEFINITION,
YOU'RE LOOKING AT AROUND ALMOST
A MILLION IN CALIFORNIA ALONE.
SO 996, A LITTLE OVER 996,000,
SO, YOU KNOW, THOSE ARE TWO VERY
DIFFERENT NUMBERS, BUT THEY'RE
REALLY BASED ON THE STATE'S
DEFINITION OF WHAT IS UNSERVED
AND THE STATE'S DEFINITION IS,
AGAIN, BASED ON SPECIFIC
TECHNOLOGY TYPE. SO IT'S MORE
BINARY. THERE'S NO UNDERSERVED
IN THAT COUNT. IT'S ALL
UNSERVED. THE STATE COUNT WAS
900 AND 996, AND SO HOW THESE
PROGRAMS FIT TOGETHER, I WOULD
SAY THAT, YOU KNOW, AT THE END
OF THE DAY, THE STATE IS
COMMITTED. IT HAS A REALLY BOLD
VISION OF REACHING EVERY SINGLE
LAST ONE OF THESE LOCATIONS
ACROSS, REGARDLESS OF HOW
THEY'RE DEFINED, AND WHAT WE
HAVE SEEN BASED ON, JUST ON THE
FEDERAL FUNDING ACCOUNT AND THE
DEMAND AND THE APPLICATIONS THAT
HAVE COME IN FOR THAT PROGRAM,
WE REALLY DO SEE THAT EVERY LAST
PENNY OF THAT IS VERY MUCH
NEEDED IN ORDER TO SERVE ONE TO
HIT AS MANY OF THOSE LOCATIONS
AS POSSIBLE. AND ALSO IT HAS TO
BE DONE IN, IN TANDEM AND, AND,
OR ORCHESTRATED WITH THE BEAD
FUNDING, WHICH IS FORTHCOMING.
YEAH. AND I UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE MAY BE DIFFERENT
DEFINITIONS. I JUST THINK THAT,
YOU KNOW, WE NEED TO BE CLEAR ON
WHICH DEFINITION WE ARE USING
AND, AND HOW WE ARE DEFINING
SUCCESS AND WHAT METRICS THAT WE
ARE USING FOR THIS PROGRAM.
BECAUSE THIS IS PROBABLY THE
LAST MAJOR INFLUX OF FUNDING
WE'RE GOING TO GET FOR A WHILE
IN THIS AREA. SO HOW ARE YOU
DEFINING SUCCESS, THIS WHAT ARE
YOUR GOALS BY THE END OF THIS,
THIS MONEY BEING SPENT, IT IS
JUST AS MARIA POINTED OUT, IT
WOULD BE TO ACCOMPLISH SERVICE
TO ALL THE UNSERVED AND
UNDERSERVED LOCATIONS AS DEFINED
BY THOSE SPECIFIC PROGRAMS. BUT
YOU THINK THAT'S DOABLE WITH THE
CURRENT TRAJECTORY WE'RE ON. AND
I THINK THAT WE ARE GOING TO,
NOT NECESSARILY ACHIEVE IT ALL
THE WAY WITH THIS CURRENT ROUND
OF FUNDING. BUT I THINK WE'RE
GOING TO GET A LOT CLOSER THAN
WE HAVE BEEN IN THE PAST. WE'RE
SEEING A LOT OF NEW ENTRANTS
INTO THIS SPACE THROUGH THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE GRANTS AND
THE FFA GRANT APPLICATIONS THAT
WE'VE GOT COMING IN THE DOOR.
AND SO I THINK WE'RE ABOUT TO
SEE A REAL CHANGE IN THE
BROADBAND MARKETPLACE IN
CALIFORNIA IS THAT NEW
TECHNOLOGIES MEAN THAT INCLUDE
LIKE FIXED WIRELESS OR OTHER NEW
TECHNOLOGY AS WELL. IS THAT WHAT
YOU MEAN, OR IS THAT DO YOU MEAN
I MEAN, WELL, LIKE WHAT I WAS
SAYING BY A NEW ENTRANCE, WHAT I
MEANT THERE WAS THE, THE NEW
PUBLIC ENTITIES THAT ARE COMING
INTO THE MARKETPLACE IN ORDER TO
SERVE THE COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVEN'T BEEN SERVED. SO WE HAVE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS, TRIBES, NEW
SPECIAL DISTRICTS THAT HAVE COME
IN AND ARE APPLYING FOR FFA
FUNDS. AS FAR AS TECHNOLOGIES,
FFA IS A FIBER FOCUSED PROGRAM.
I THINK WE SPOKE ABOUT THIS
BEFORE. BEAD IS A TECHNOLOGY,
NEUTRAL, MORE BROADER TECHNOLOGY
NEUTRAL PROGRAM. AND FIXED
WIRELESS IS ELIGIBLE WITHIN
BEAD. YEAH. I'VE ASKED MY TEAM
TO SET UP A FOLLOW UP, I MEAN, I
CERTAINLY I THINK, YOU KNOW,
SPEAKING FOR MYSELF AND, AND YOU
KNOW, WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS IN
NEGOTIATIONS. I CERTAINLY DON'T
FEEL COMFORTABLE. I KNOW THERE'S
I'M NOT SURE IF THERE'S ANY
SPECIFIC CHANGES IN THE
REVISION. I KNOW WE HAD
INITIALLY, I THINK 46, WAS IT
SAY AGAIN, THERE'S 200 DELAY IN
THIS REVISION, AND THEN SOME IN
THE JANUARY PROPOSAL. THERE'S
STILL SOME ADDITIONAL POSITIONS
THAT ARE REQUESTED. RIGHT? YEAH.
I KNOW FOR MYSELF I JUST I NEED
TO GET A CLEAR PICTURE OF, OF
THE GOALS AND THE METRICS AND,
AND HOW, HOW WE ARE GOING TO GET
THERE. LIKE HOW WILL THESE
INTERMEDIARIES FACTOR IN HOW
THEY ARE? HOW DOES THAT GET US
TO THE GOAL? AND ARE WE
MEASURING AGAINST THE 900 AND
909, 996,000? ARE WE MEASURING
AGAINST THE 456,000? BUT, YOU
KNOW, HOW ARE WE YOU KNOW, BY
WHAT TIME FRAME ARE WE GOING TO
MEASURE AND SAY, OKAY, HERE'S
WHAT WE'VE ACHIEVED, AND WE'LL
BE ABLE TO SAY, YOU KNOW, WHAT
WE ACHIEVED WITH THIS PROGRAM
BECAUSE IT'S JUST AN
EXTRAORDINARY AMOUNT OF MONEY,
AND THIS IS REALLY OUR
OPPORTUNITY. SO I WON'T BELABOR
IT HERE. AT THIS POINT, BUT I'LL
JUST SAY THIS IS, YOU KNOW,
SOMEWHAT HELPFUL. BUT YOU KNOW,
I UNDERSTAND THERE'S SORT OF
DIFFERENT METRICS. AND I'M
CERTAINLY GOING TO JUST FOR MY
OWN STANDPOINT, REQUEST A FOLLOW
UP SO I CAN UNDERSTAND THIS
BETTER. ARE WE USING THE FEDERAL
FUNDS FIRST, BY THE WAY? BECAUSE
I KNOW THERE'S LIMITED WINDOW
FOR FEDERAL FUNDS. ARE WE USING
THE FEDERAL FUNDS, FIRST AND
SAVING OUR GENERAL FUND DOLLARS?
YES, WE ARE, SENATOR. YES. OKAY.
THAT IS THAT IS PART OF THE
PLAN. OKAY THAT'S GOOD. I THINK
THAT WAS, CLEAR INITIALLY. OKAY.
ANYTHING ELSE ON BEAD WE WANT TO
ASK THERE, TOO? WE'RE HAPPY TO
HAVE THE FOLLOW UP WITH YOUR
OFFICE. OKAY. THANK YOU. I
APPRECIATE THAT. LET'S SEE, I
HAVE ONE THING I HAVE TO GET TO
FORBID. MAYBE I'LL JUST START ON
OFFSHORE WIND IF ANYONE'S TO
PICK UP. MAYBE. SENATOR DONNELLY
WOULD WANT TO WANT TO PICK UP ON
THIS ONE, HOW WILL THE, IF WE
CAN GET THE RIGHT FOLKS HERE?
THERE WAS A REDUCTION FOR
OFFSHORE WIND INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND THE QUESTION INITIALLY IS,
IS DO YOU ANTICIPATE FUNDING THE
SAME NUMBER OF PROJECTS JUST AT
A LOWER LEVEL OR FEWER, PROJECTS
, WE KNOW THAT FROM THE AB 525
REPORT THAT LAUNCHING OFFSHORE
WIND INDUSTRY REQUIRES MANY
WORKSTREAMS COMING TOGETHER. AND
KAISER IS PROPOSING ITS FIRST
MAJOR TRANSMISSION UPGRADE TO
ACCESS HUMBOLDT OFFSHORE WIND.
WE ALSO KNOW HUMBOLDT, I THINK
$400 MILLION IN IN IN FUNDING
FOR THEIR, PORT. BUT AND I KNOW
WE'RE CONSIDERING IMPLEMENTATION
OF CENTRAL PROCUREMENT FOR
OFFSHORE WIND. THAT WAS ONE OF
OUR BIG INITIATIVES LAST YEAR.
OUR PORTS ARE THE THIRD LEG OF
THE STOOL. SO DOES THIS CUT PUT,
THE OFFSHORE WIND STRATEGY AT
RISK, FOR CUTTING MONEY TO THE
PORTS, DAMIAN, OR INFRASTRUCTURE
IN GENERAL? I'M SORRY. DID I CUT
YOU OFF? NO. GO AHEAD. OKAY,
DAMIAN MÐI WITH THE ENERGY
COMMISSION AGAIN, SO THE
PROPOSED BUDGET WOULD LEAVE
ABOUT $9 MILLION AVAILABLE FOR
THE PROGRAM. SO WITH THAT, WE
WOULD LOOK FORWARD TO FUNDING
THE HIGHEST PRIORITY PROJECTS AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE. THAT INCLUDES,
CONSTRUCTION OF STAGING FLOATING
PLATFORMS, FOUNDATIONS AND
LOOKING FORWARD TO OPERATIONS
AND MAINTENANCE. OKAY. YEAH. I
MEAN, MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
THIS IS GOING TO REQUIRE A
CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF MONEY,
ALSO SOMETHING TO BE CONSIDERED
IN A CLIMATE BOND, WHICH WHICH
WE'D LOVE TO SEE, PASSED, SO I
GUESS REALLY SPECIFIC TO THE
QUESTION, DO YOU SEE FUNDING THE
SAME NUMBER OF PROJECTS OR AT A
LOWER LEVEL, OR FEWER PROJECTS?
I THINK IT WOULD MOST LIKELY BE
FEWER PROJECTS GIVEN THE SCALE
OF THE PROJECTS. HOWEVER, WE'D
HAVE TO, UNDER THE CURRENT
PROGRAM, WE'D BE LOOKING AT A
COMPETITIVE SOLICITATION. AND SO
THAT WOULD BE SOMETHING THAT
WOULD BE CONSIDERED AS PART OF
THE AWARD PROCESS. OKAY. GREAT.
ANY FOLLOW UP ON THAT OR. YEAH
SO WAS THE COMPETITIVE PROCESS,
PRIVATE MONEY, IT WOULD BE AN
AWARD OF, OF PUBLIC FUNDS OF THE
GENERAL FUND AWARD, AVAILABLE TO
THE OUT OF THE 9 MILLION TI¾N.
CORRECT? YES. OKAY YEAH. GREAT.
I KNOW I MIGHT GET TOUCHED ON BY
MY COLLEAGUE HERE, BUT THERE WAS
A PIECE THAT WAS PROPOSED, I
THINK MAYBE ADDITIONAL MONEY OR
MONEY ADDED BACK IN AROUND ONE,
TWO PERMANENT POSITIONS, TO
PROCESS CONSOLIDATED PERMITS,
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK THAT
OBVIOUSLY HAS TO HAPPEN IN A
NUMBER OF AGENCIES, AS WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT IN THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE, ABOUT,
COLLABORATION AMONG DIFFERENT
AGENCIES. SO MAYBE YOU CAN TELL
US A LITTLE ABOUT THE EXPERTISE
REQUIRED FOR SOME OF THESE
POSITIONS. AND AND WHETHER THEY
MAY REVISE WILL HAVE SUFFICIENT
FUNDING TO WORK ON THESE
PROJECTS. IS THAT CLEAR? THANK
YOU. SENATOR, I THINK YOU'RE
SPEAKING ABOUT THE COASTAL
COMMISSION PORTION OF THE JOINT
PCB HERE. EXACTLY. YES. THANK
YOU, YEAH. SO THE COASTAL
COMMISSION WOULD BE RECEIVING,
5.3 MILLION UNDER THIS PROPOSAL
FOR 2024, AND THEN AND TWO
PERMANENT POSITIONS, PLUS 1.5
MILLION IN 24, 25 FOR, PLANNING
AND MANAGEMENT. AND SO THE TYPE
OF EXPERTISE WE WOULD BE
BRINGING IN IS LARGELY
PERMITTING STAFF, WITH SOME
TECHNICAL EXPERTS INCLUDED, THE
THERE'S A LOT OF, THE COASTAL
COMMISSION HAS AUTHORITY BOTH IN
FEDERAL WATERS, STATE WATERS.
AND THEN WE'LL BE DOING
CONSOLIDATE PERMITS ON THE
ONSHORE COMPONENTS OF OFFSHORE
WIND. SO IT'S A VERY LARGE
PERMITTING LOAD. SO I THINK
THIS, FUNDING WOULD PROVIDE
THREE YEARS OF STAFFING TO GET
US REALLY A SOLID FOOTING
TOWARDS THAT PERMITTING GOAL.
OKAY. AND FOR THE RECORD, I
APOLOGIZE. I'M KATE ZUCKERBERG,
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
COASTAL COMMISSION. MY
APOLOGIES. WELL, SO MY
COLLEAGUES MAY HAVE SOME FOLLOW
UP FOR YOU. I HAVE TO GO. DO YOU
ATTEND TO ONE MEASURE? I'M GOING
TO HAND THE GAVEL OVER TO. SO I
JUST WANTED. HELLO NICE TO SEE
YOU. THANK YOU ALL FOR COMING. I
JUST WANTED TO ASK ABOUT IN
PREVIOUS CONVERSATIONS, THE
COASTAL COMMISSION HAS SAID THAT
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH FUNDING TO
STAFF POSITIONS TO PROCESS
HOUSING PERMITS, SO I WANTED TO
UNDERSTAND HOW, ESPECIALLY
MULTIFAMILY HOUSING PERMITS AND
MAYBE MORE COMPLICATED PERMITS
IN THE COASTAL ZONE. SO I WANTED
TO JUST UNDERSTAND THIS FUNDING
REQUEST AND STAFFING FOR IT
VERSUS OTHER PRIORITIES. THE
COASTAL COMMISSION HAS AND THE
STATE HAS. IF YOU COULD FILL
THAT IN A LITTLE BIT. THANK YOU,
SENATOR BLAKESBURG, THOSE ARE
BOTH PRIORITIES FOR THE COASTAL
COMMISSION. SO THIS OFFSHORE
WIND PROPOSAL IS A NEED THAT WE
HAVE FOR TO CONTINUE PERMITTING
FOR OFFSHORE WIND. THERE ARE
ALSO NEEDS TO WORK ON HOUSING.
AND WE DO HAVE ONE PROPOSAL, A
SMALL ONE RIGHT NOW, FOR, FOR
23, IMPLEMENTATION THAT WOULD
INCLUDE A POSITION. SO WE'RE,
WE'RE WORKING ON THAT AS WELL.
THEY'RE DEFINITELY BOTH
IMPORTANT PRIORITIES FOR THE
COMMISSION. OKAY. THANK YOU.
SORRY. YEP JUST MAYBE A QUICK
FOLLOW UP ON THE, OFFSHORE WIND
I'VE BEEN OPPOSED TO. OBVIOUSLY,
IT'S NO SECRET I'VE BEEN OPPOSED
TO OFFSHORE WIND AND THE MANNER
THAT WE'RE GOING ABOUT IT. SO
THIS IS JUST THE SEED MONEY TO
THE COASTAL COMMISSION TO DO THE
PERMITTING PROCESS ON THE COAST.
RIGHT. THE ACTUAL LAST YEAR,
THEY TOLD US WE WERE GOING TO
HAVE, UNDER SB 386, I THINK IT
IS 286, YOU KNOW, WE WERE GOING
TO HAVE GENERAL FUND MONIES HELP
BUILD THIS STUFF. AND SO I'M I'M
CONFUSED OF WHAT THE PLAN IS
HERE MOVING FORWARD. SO MAYBE
SOMEBODY COULD HELP ME. I KNOW
THERE'S A FEW MILLION DOLLARS
HERE TO GO TO THE COASTAL
COMMISSION TO, I GUESS PLAN AND
MAYBE YOU CAN HELP ME OUT HERE.
YES. HAPPY TO THANK YOU. LIZZIE.
YOUR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SO
THE MAY REVISION PRESENTS A $16
MILLION GENERAL FUND PACKAGE FOR
VARIOUS OFFSHORE WIND ENERGY
ACTIVITIES AT THE COASTAL
COMMISSION, STATE LANDS
COMMISSION AND OCEAN PROTECTION
COUNCIL TO FUND ACTIVITIES OVER
THE NEXT THREE YEARS. SO WE WERE
VERY MINDFUL OF THE STATE'S
FISCAL CONSTRAINTS. WE LOOKED AT
ALL THE OFFSHORE WIND ACTIVITIES
HOLISTICALLY, SO WE REALLY TRIED
TO PRESENT A STRATEGIC PACKAGE
TO ADDRESS THESE WORKLOAD NEEDS
OVER THE NEXT THREE YEARS. AND
SO WHAT IS THE WHAT'S THE PLAN
BETWEEN NOW AND 2035 WHEN WE
HAVE ALL ELECTRIC CARS IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE GOING TO BE
RELYING ON THIS OFFSHORE WIND IS
WHERE'S THE RESOURCES COME TO
BUILD BUILD OFFSHORE WIND
PROJECTS LIKE ACTUALLY PUT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE OUT THERE. THIS
IS THE PLANNING PART OF IT. IS
THERE ANY THOUGHT ON THAT, WE
WILL CONTINUE TO EVALUATE
OFFSHORE WIND RESOURCE NEEDS.
AGAIN, THIS PROPOSAL IS REALLY
JUST THE INITIAL THREE YEARS OF
FUNDING NEEDED TO CONTINUE THE
IMPORTANT WORK AT THESE
DEPARTMENTS. HOWEVER WE PLAN TO
RECONSIDER ADDITIONAL FUNDING IN
FUTURE BUDGET CYCLES. OKAY.
ANYBODY ELSE WANT TO GIVE IT A
SHOT? NO. OKAY. ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS ON OFFSHORE WIND? OKAY
SENATOR BLAKE, DO YOU HAVE WHAT
DO WE WOULD THAT GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT. YOU CAN GO ON TO PUBLIC
COMMENT. ARE YOU ARE YOU DONE
WITH ALL THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
THAT YOU HAVE? OKAY. SO WITH
THAT, THANK YOU ALL FOR COMING.
GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN, WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE INTO THE PUBLIC
COMMENT PART OF, FOR THOSE
WISHING TO ADDRESS THE BOARD
UNDER, OR THE COMMITTEE UNDER
PUBLIC COMMENT, YOU HAVE A WHOLE
LESS THAN TWO MINUTES, WE WOULD
LIKE TO GET THROUGH THIS SOON,
BUT, YOU MAY START. THANK YOU.
BILL MAGAVERN WITH THE COALITION
FOR CLEAN AIR. JUST TWO QUICK
POINTS, ONE ONE IS THE AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL FUND SHOULD BE
USED TO CONTROL AIR POLLUTION.
THIS IS MONEY THAT COMES FROM
FINES AND PENALTIES PAID BY
THOSE WHO VIOLATE OUR AIR
POLLUTION LAWS. AND THEY'RE
DIRTYING THE AIR. SO THE MONEY
THAT THEY PAY SHOULD BE USED TO
CLEAN UP THE AIR. CALIFORNIA HAS
THE WORST AIR POLLUTION IN THE
WHOLE COUNTRY, CALIFORNIANS ARE
NOT BREATHING CLEAN AIR. WE'RE
IN VIOLATION OF FEDERAL
STANDARDS UNDER THE CLEAN AIR
ACT, AND THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
CAN SANCTION US FOR THAT. SO
WHAT IS EPA GOING TO THINK IF
THEY SEE THAT CALIFORNIA IS
RAISING MONEY THAT IS SUPPOSED
TO BE DEDICATED TO CONTROLLING
AIR POLLUTION, AND INSTEAD IS
DIVERTING THAT MONEY FOR OTHER
PURPOSES, AND THAT'S MONEY THAT
CAN BE SPENT TO REINVIGORATE THE
ZEV PROGRAMS FOR CLEAN CARS FOR
ALL, FOR CLEAN TRUCKS, BUSSES
AND OFF ROAD EQUIPMENT.
SECONDLY, THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND, WE NEED TO AS AS
YOU, SENATOR DALY AND CHAIR
BECKER HAVE POINTED OUT, WE NEED
TO PRIORITIZE REDUCING
TRANSPORTATION EMISSIONS. AND
THAT INCLUDES OUR IMPORTANT ZEV
PROGRAMS. AS I'VE MENTIONED, FOR
CLEAN CARS, BUSSES, TRUCKS, OFF
ROAD EQUIPMENT AND THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT PROP
IT UP. I I WANT TO BE I LOVE TO
HEAR FROM THE PUBLIC, BUT WE
HAVE A LINE OUT THE DOOR, SO
OKAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, JENNIFER
FEARING FIRST, ON BEHALF OF THE
MONTEREY BAY AQUARIUM, WE'RE
HAPPY TO SEE THE FIRST HALF OF
THE FUNDS PROMISED BY AB 1373 OF
LAST YEAR TO GIVE OPC, THE FUNDS
AHEAD OF OFFSHORE WIND
DEVELOPMENT, TO DO SCIENTIFIC
RESEARCH AND ROBUST CONSULTATION
WITH TRIBES AND IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES. WE URGE THE FULL 6
MILLION TO BE IN THE FINAL
BUDGET PACKAGE, AND WE'RE VERY
KEEN TO SEE THE IMPLEMENTING
LANGUAGE TO MAKE SURE IT MEETS
WITH THE OBJECTIVES THAT THE
AQUARIUM ASSEMBLY MEMBER ADDIS
AND SENATOR LAIRD AND OTHERS
HAVE WITH AB 80, WHICH IS
CURRENTLY PENDING IN THE SENATE.
SECONDLY NATIONAL WILDLIFE
FEDERATION AND THE SAN DIEGO
HUMANE SOCIETY. JOIN A NUMBER OF
SENATORS. THANK THANK YOU, ALL
OF YOU IN OPPOSING THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL TO
ELIMINATE THE GENERAL FUND
SUPPORT FOR THE HABITAT
CONSERVATION FUND, SIX YEARS
AHEAD OF THE SUNSET DATE THAT
WAS NEGOTIATED WITH THE
LEGISLATURE IN 2019. THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR SPEAKING UP ABOUT THAT
ONE. AND LASTLY, ON BEHALF OF A
NUMBER OF ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
PART OF A 170 ORGANIZATION
COALITION THAT ARE PUSHING FOR A
EQUITABLE, ROBUST CLIMATE BOND,
WE URGE THAT THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE GOVERNOR COME TOGETHER
QUICKLY AND SOON IN ORDER TO PUT
SUCH A BOND BEFORE VOTERS THIS
FALL. THANK YOU, THANK YOU. NEXT
WITNESS. GOOD AFTERNOON, KIM
DELFINO, ON BEHALF OF AUDUBON
CALIFORNIA DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE, CAL TROUT, CALIFORNIA
NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY AND THE
POWER NATURE COALITION, FOUR
POINTS, ONE IS THE SHIFT OF
FUNDING FROM GRF TO THE TIMBER
TAX, REVENUE. WE WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS UNDER SB 901 AND
THAT GRF MONEY FOLLOWS THAT
MONEY. SO WE ARE GETTING
REPORTING BACK ON THE BENEFITS
OF THOSE INVESTMENTS TO FIRE
PROJECTS. SECONDLY, WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE GRF FUND SHIFT FOR
THE WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD
FOR THE SALTON SEA AND FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE'S WETLANDS PROGRAM, I
WOULD ECHO THE COMMENTS THAT
HAVE ALREADY BEEN MADE VERY ABLY
BY THE SENATORS HERE OPPOSING
THE HABITAT CONSERVATION FUND,
SUNSET THIS YEAR AND ALSO THE
RESCISSION OF $45 MILLION. THAT
WOULD BE MOST OF THE HCF THAT'S
CURRENTLY, IN THERE RIGHT NOW,
THAT'S A HUGE CUT. IT SEEMS KIND
OF 4/5. AND I MEAN, WHY ARE WE
DOING THIS? WE TRIED THEY TRIED
IT IN 2020 AND IT DIDN'T GO
ANYWHERE. SO, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS ON THAT.
AND FINALLY, TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE BY MISS
FEARING THE BUDGET THIS YEAR IS
BAD, THE BUDGET NEXT YEAR IS
PROBABLY GOING TO BE WORSE, AND
THE BUDGET AFTER THAT IS GOING
TO BE EVEN WORSE. IF WE'RE GOING
TO BE MAKING OUR CLIMATE GOALS,
OUR NATURAL WORKING LANDS,
NATURE BASED SOLUTION GOALS, OUR
ENERGY GOALS, ALL THE GOALS WE
HAVE SET, WE NEED ONGOING AND
DEDICATED FUNDING. WE HAVE USED
BONDS IN THE PAST TO BRIDGE THE
GAP, AND WE WOULD URGE THE
PASSAGE OF A STRONG CLIMATE BOND
NOW. THANK YOU, THANK YOU. NEXT
WITNESS. GOOD AFTERNOON, MR.
CHAIR. SENATOR BLAKE SPEAR, BETH
OLAZO, ON BEHALF OF WATER REUSE
CALIFORNIA, HERE. DISAPPOINTED
TO SEE ANOTHER $100 MILLION, GET
CUT FROM WATER RECYCLING. THAT
MAKES IT 70% OF ALL THE FUNDS
THAT WE ORIGINALLY ALLOCATED,
AND THERE'S NO MONEY LEFT AT THE
STATE BOARD FOR GRANTS FOR WATER
RECYCLING. AS YOU KNOW, IT'S
REALLY CRITICAL. TO HELP MEET
OUR, OUR WATER SUPPLY GOALS, TO
INVEST IN NEW WATER RECYCLING
PROJECTS. WE HOPE THAT WE
UNDERSTAND THE BUDGET SITUATION,
BUT WE HOPE THAT THE COMMITTEE
CAN GET BEHIND SIGNIFICANT
FUNDING IN THE CLIMATE BOND FOR
WATER RECYCLING, IT KEEPS
RATEPAYER COSTS DOWN. THESE
PROJECTS, YOU KNOW, ARE ARE
CRITICAL AND WE'RE JUST TRYING
TO PROTECT RATEPAYER COSTS. SO
REALLY URGE CONTINUED SUPPORT
FOR WATER RECYCLING. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. MY
NAME IS KENDRA HARRIS. THE
CLIMATE CENTER, WE KNOW IT'S A
TOUGH BUDGET CYCLE, BUT THE MAY
REVISE SHIFTS AN ADDITIONAL 3.6
BILLION OF CLIMATE AND CLEAN AIR
INVESTMENTS TO THE GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION FUND OVER THE NEXT
FIVE YEARS. IN THE PAST, FINANCE
WOULDN'T COMMIT TO OUT YEAR OUT
YEAR FUND FOR GOOD REASON.
THERE'S A LOT OF UNCERTAINTY IN
PREDICTING REVENUES IN THAT
PROGRAM EVEN A COUPLE OF YEARS
OUT. AND THE FARTHER FORWARD THE
LEGISLATURE CAN BRING THOSE
EXPENDITURES, THE MORE LIKELY
THEY ARE TO HAPPEN. AND LET'S BE
CLEAR, CUTS TO CRITICAL CLEAN
AIR AND CLIMATE PROGRAMS HAVE
REAL, IMMEDIATE HUMAN
CONSEQUENCES, ESPECIALLY TO
POLLUTION BURDENED COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR, WE SHOULD ALSO NOT BE
CUTTING THE TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM WHEN THE LEGISLATURE
COULD SHIFT MONEY FROM THE STATE
HIGHWAY ACCOUNT, WHICH IS WELL
FUNDED AND HAS BEEN DONE IN THE
PAST, AND WE FACE AN
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA AND HELPING RESIDENTS
MOVE TO CLEAN, CHEAPER, SAFE
ENERGY IS CRITICAL, THIS WILL
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIANS AND
THEIR CHILDREN HAVE A THRIVING
FUTURE, AND WE ALSO SUPPORT A
ROBUST CLIMATE BOND. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. BRENDAN TÔI, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION, WHICH IS THE AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL OFFICERS FROM
ALL 35 LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS. WE
APPRECIATE THE CONTINUED FUNDING
AND PRIORITIZATION OF THE AB 617
COMMUNITY AIR PROTECTION
PROGRAM. UNFORTUNATELY THE
FARMER PROGRAM IS STILL ZEROED
OUT AND WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO MAKE
A MEANINGFUL INVESTMENT IN THIS
EFFICIENT, COST EFFECTIVE
PROGRAM THAT PROVIDES
SIGNIFICANT, PUBLIC HEALTH
BENEFITS AS WELL AS CLIMATE
BENEFITS. AND I ALSO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT, MUCH OF THOSE
HEALTH BENEFITS ARE IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
SENATOR BLAKE SPEAR, GOOD
AFTERNOON, LOUIS BROWN. TODAY ON
A COALITION OF AGRICULTURAL
CLIENTS. FIRST, JUST ECHO WHAT
MR. TÔI JUST SAID ABOUT THE
FARMER PROGRAM AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF THAT PROGRAM. TWO
OTHER QUICK ISSUES IN SUPPORT OF
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR FRUIT FLY
ERADICATION. IF THOSE MONIES
AREN'T AVAILABLE, WE'LL LOSE
FEDERAL FUNDS AND POTENTIALLY
HAVE SIGNIFICANT INTERNATIONAL
RAMIFICATIONS. IF WE WERE TO
LOSE THE STATUS AS BEING FRUIT
FLY FREE, FINALLY, ASKED THAT
THE, BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE REJECT
THE RECENT BCP FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATIONS FOR ADDITIONAL FIVE
STAFF MEMBERS FOR BILLS THAT
WERE SIGNED LAST YEAR. THEIR
JANUARY BCP IS A 43% BUDGET
INCREASE AND 117 STAFF PEOPLE.
WE THINK THAT WITHIN THOSE STAFF
PEOPLE, THEY CAN FIND THE NEED
OR THE RESOURCES TO IMPLEMENT
THE BILLS FROM LAST YEAR. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MR. CHAIRMAN AND SENATOR
BLAKE SPEAR. MY NAME IS DAN
JACOBSON WITH ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA, SPEAKING IN SUPPORT
OF OFFSHORE WIND. I WANTED TO
MAKE A COUPLE OF POINTS. FIRST
IS IMPORTANT TO RESTORE THE FULL
$45 MILLION FOR THE PORTS AND
FOR THE FUNDING. I KNOW THERE
WAS BACK AND FORTH ON THAT, BUT
AS HAS BEEN SAID, IF WE DON'T
HAVE THE PORTS UP AND READY TO
GO, WE CAN'T GET THE TURBINES
OUT INTO THE WATER. WE CAN'T GET
THE CLEAN ENERGY IN THE BACK AND
FORTH THERE. THE SECOND IS
ENSURING THE $6 MILLION FOR THE
OPC TO BE ABLE TO DO THE
SCIENTIFIC STUDIES. WE DON'T
WANT TO BE SLOWED DOWN BECAUSE
WE DON'T HAVE THE INFORMATION
THAT WE NEED. AND THE FINAL IS
MAKING SURE THAT THE COASTAL
COMMISSION HAS THE STAFF THAT
THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT.
THE RECENT BCP, WE SAW THAT WE
THINK THAT'S A MOVE IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. WE THINK THAT'S
SMART. THE LETTER THAT WE'LL BE
SUBMITTING TODAY IS SUPPORTED BY
THE BUILDING TRADES, BY THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF PORT
AUTHORITIES, BY VARIOUS
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS AND
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE GROUPS. SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU. NICOLE HUTCHINSON, ON
BEHALF OF CAL, START URGING YOU
TODAY TO PROTECT INVESTMENTS IN
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY, ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE AND
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS,
WHICH HAVE LARGELY BEEN ZEROED
OUT THIS FISCAL YEAR. AND IN THE
CASE OF ZEV INFRASTRUCTURE,
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS IS ALSO
BEING CLAWED BACK. AS YOU NOTED
TODAY, THESE PROGRAMS ARE
CRITICAL FOR ACHIEVING THE
STATE'S AIR QUALITY AND CLIMATE
GOALS AND CREATE JOBS. SO I
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO RESTORE
THIS IMPORTANT FUNDING. THANKS.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR
DALI. SENATOR BLAKE SPEAR NICOLE
MOLINA, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF ITEM NUMBER 3540,
WHICH WOULD PERMANENTLY FUND
FIVE CAL FIRE FIREFIGHTER
HANDCREWS. THESE CREWS PLAY AN
ESSENTIAL ROLE IN THE STATE'S
WILDFIRE PREVENTION AND
SUPPRESSION EFFORTS. CAL FOREST
URGES THE LEGISLATURE TO APPROVE
THIS APPROVAL. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, TRACY RYAN WITH THE
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA, IN OPPOSITION TO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO ELIMINATE
THE BROADBAND LOAN LOSS RESERVE
PROGRAM, THIS PROGRAM ALREADY
WAS REDUCED IN EARLY ACTION BY
$150 MILLION, WE REPRESENT 37
MUNICIPALITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
WAITING THREE YEARS FOR THIS
FUNDING, AND WE ARE IN THE
APPLICATION PROCESS NOW. WE'RE
WAITING AWARDS AT THIS MOMENT.
SO WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
REINSTATE THE FUNDING. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON,
DOCTOR JEFF BOEHM WITH THE
MARINE MAMMAL CENTER AND
REPRESENTING 12 NETWORK MEMBERS
FROM SAN DIEGO UP TO THE OREGON
BORDER AND IN OPPOSITION TO THE
CUT OF $2 MILLION IN ANNUAL
ONGOING FUNDING TO THAT NETWORK.
THE FUNDING HAS BEEN IN PLACE
FOR THE ENTIRE NETWORK SINCE
2015, AND ORIGINALLY AS A CRISIS
INTERVENTION, THEN ENSURING
RESILIENCY OF THE NETWORK AND
FINALLY PRESENTING A FRONTLINE
FOR DISEASE SURVEILLANCE. WE
STRONGLY URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
OPPOSE THE CUT IN THIS FUNDING.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. HI ASHA
SHARMA, ON BEHALF OF LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY, WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO RESTORE AND
PROTECT FUNDING FOR THE PROGRAMS
THAT SUPPORT ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE. COMMUNITIES IN
PARTICULAR, THE MAY REVISE
INCLUDED AN ADDITIONAL CUT OF
130 MILLION TO THE CCS EQUITABLE
BUILDING DECARBONIZATION
PROGRAM. THE FUNDING SHOULD BE
RESTORED TO THE 639 MILLION FROM
THE JANUARY BUDGET PROPOSAL. WE
ALSO RECOMMEND RESTORING THE
FOLLOWING ORIGINALLY ALLOCATED
TO THESE SCC PROGRAMS 200
MILLION FOR TRANSFORMATIVE
CLIMATE COMMUNITIES, 9.8 MILLION
FOR REGIONAL CLIMATE
COLLABORATIVES AND 160 MILLION
FOR COMMUNITY RESILIENCE
CENTERS. WE APPRECIATE THE MAY
REVISES CONTINUED COMMITMENT TO
DRINKING WATER AND WASTEWATER
NEEDS AND THE SALTON SEA, AND WE
CONTINUE TO ASK FOR
MULTI-BENEFIT INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
THE SALTON SEA. WE ALSO URGE THE
LEGISLATURE NOT TO FUND FALSE
CLIMATE CHANGE SOLUTIONS LIKE
CFA'S DAIRY DIGESTER AND
RESEARCH DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM,
WHICH POLLUTES ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. ABBY
ALVAREZ WITH THE PESTICIDE
ACTION NETWORK. CALIFORNIANS FOR
PESTICIDE REFORM IN THE
CALIFORNIA FOOD AND FARMING
NETWORK. FIRST, WE'RE IN SUPPORT
OF THE FUNDING FOR RECENTLY
CHAPTERED AB 652. WE ALSO WANT
TO COMMENT ON THE GOVERNOR'S
MILFY PROPOSAL. WE'VE SUBMITTED
A SERIES OF PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
IN WRITING AND WANT TO UPLIFT
THE NEED FOR ENFORCEABLE
COMMITMENTS TO COMPLETE, NOT
JUST START PESTICIDE
REEVALUATIONS AND EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT, TO MITIGATE WITHIN A
SPECIFIED TIMELINE. WE WANT TO
ALIGN THE BUDGET WITH THE
AMENDMENTS MADE IN AB 2113.
LASTLY, THE CALIFORNIA FOOD AND
FARMING NETWORK WANTS TO OPPOSE
CUTS TO THE CALIFORNIA NUTRITION
INCENTIVE PROGRAM. THE FARM TO
COMMUNITY HUB PROGRAM, AND THE
CALIFORNIA UNDERSERVED AND SMALL
PRODUCER PROGRAM. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON.
REBECCA MARCUS, SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA CERTIFIED
ORGANIC FARMERS AND THE
COMMUNITY ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY
FARMERS WHILE ACKNOWLEDGING THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET DEFICIT, WE ARE
DISAPPOINTED BY THE ADDITIONAL
CUTS MADE TO CRITICAL DISASTER
RELIEF FOR THE MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIA'S FARMS. COUGH AND
COUGH ERJ BUDGET REVISIONS TO
RESTORE 17.9 MILLION TO CFA'S
CUSP PROGRAM. THE CALIFORNIA
UNDERSERVED AND SMALL PRODUCER
PROGRAM, AS WELL AS 14.4 MILLION
TO CFA'S FARM TO COMMUNITY FOOD
HUB PROGRAM FOR ESSENTIAL SUPPLY
CHAIN INFRASTRUCTURE RESOURCES.
ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE AND AGRICULTURE NETWORK,
I ASK YOU TO MOVE THE PROPOSED
GRF SHIFT FOR STATE WATER FOR
THE STATE WATER EFFICIENCY
ENERGY PROGRAM, ALSO KNOWN AS
SWEEP, FROM FY 26 TO 27 TO FY
24, 25 FARMERS HAD APPLICATIONS
READY TO SUBMIT WHEN THIS
SOLICITATION OPENED BRIEFLY LAST
DECEMBER. ONLY ONLY TO BE TOLD
WITHIN A FEW WEEKS THAT THEY THE
MONEY WAS GOING TO BE REVERTED
BACK TO THE GENERAL FUND. THEY
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO WAIT ANOTHER
THREE YEARS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS
TOM KNOX OF VALLEY CLEAN AIR.
NOW LOW INCOME WORKING FAMILIES
IN CALIFORNIA PAY THE HIGHEST
PERCENTAGE OF THEIR MONTHLY
INCOME ON GASOLINE TO DRIVE
FARTHER AND FARTHER TO
WELL-PAYING JOBS, AS OUTLINED IN
THE SB ONE HEARING IN THE LAST
WEEK OR TWO. THERE IS A
SOLUTION. IN CALIFORNIA, THERE'S
A PROVEN PROGRAM, CLEAN CARS FOR
ALL TO REPLACE THESE OLD, DIRTY,
INEFFICIENT CARS WITH AFFORDABLE
ZEVS. WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
LOOK FOR SOLUTIONS TO USE
EXISTING FUNDS TO KEEP THIS
PROGRAM OPEN FOR THE NEXT TWO
YEARS, WHEN WE CAN FIND A LONG
TERM FUNDING SOLUTION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MR. CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MICHAEL BOCCADORO, WEST
COAST ADVISORS I WANTED TO SPEAK
BRIEFLY ON DAIRY METHANE
REDUCTION PROGRAMS. WE'RE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE $24 MILLION
SHIFT FROM THE GENERAL FUND TO
GRF FOR THE DAIRY PLUS PROGRAM
THAT'S NECESSARY IN THE BARE
MINIMUM, IT'S NEEDED TO ENSURE
55 MILLION ADDITIONAL DOLLARS IN
FEDERAL FUNDS REMAIN AVAILABLE
TO THE STATE. WE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE LOSS OF ENTIRE LOSS OF
FUNDING FOR THE DPI PROGRAM
DAIRY DIGESTER PROGRAM, AS WELL
AS THE ALTERNATIVE MANURE
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM. BOTH OF
THOSE PROGRAMS ARE HIGHLY COST
EFFECTIVE, AND IF THERE'S EVER A
YEAR WHEN WE'RE SHIFTING A LOT
OF GRF FUNDING TO NON-CLIMATE
RELATED PROGRAMS, FUNDING THOSE
THAT ARE HIGHLY COST EFFECTIVE
BECOMES CRITICALLY IMPORTANT.
AND THEN FINALLY, MR. BECKERS
$25 MILLION. THAT WAS IN THE
BUDGET LAST YEAR FOR ENTERIC
METHANE REDUCTIONS. WE'RE JUST A
FEW WEEKS AWAY FROM HAVING OUR
FIRST ENTERIC FEED ADDITIVE
APPROVED BY FDA, THE FEDERAL
LEVEL. IT'S TAKEN EIGHT YEARS.
FARMERS ARE READY TO IMPLEMENT
THOSE METHANE REDUCTIONS ON
THEIR FARMS THAT PROGRAM FUNDING
$25 MILLION IS CRITICAL AS WE GO
FORWARD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON. ALCHEMY. GRAHAM
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSIT ASSOCIATION, FIRST, WE'D
LIKE TO THANK THE LEGISLATURE
FOR ITS COMMITMENT TO PROTECTING
THE 5.1 BILLION IN SB 125
FUNDING FROM THE FISCAL YEAR
2324 BUDGET AND THE EARLY ACTION
BUDGET AGREEMENT. WE'RE ALSO
GRATEFUL TO SEE THE CRC AND ZERO
EMISSION TRANSIT CAPITAL PROGRAM
FUNDS MAINTAINED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE, AND WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO SUPPORT
MAINTENANCE OF THESE INVESTMENTS
AS CURRENTLY PROPOSED. THESE
FUNDS ARE CRITICAL IN KEEPING
PUBLIC TRANSIT ACROSS THE STATE
AFLOAT AND ALLOW TRANSIT
AGENCIES TO STAY IN COMPLIANCE
WITH THE STATE ENVIRONMENTAL AND
TRANSIT MANDATES AND OBJECTIVES.
WITH A DIFFERENT HAT ON, I'M
ALSO HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CITY TRANSPORTATION
INITIATIVE. WE REPRESENT THE
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION AND
PUBLIC WORKS DEPARTMENTS OF
CALIFORNIA'S EIGHT LARGEST
CITIES. WHILE WE FULLY
UNDERSTAND THE GRAVITY OF THE
CURRENT BUDGET OUTLOOK, WE'RE
DISHEARTENED TO SEE THE TOLL
PROPOSED $600 MILLION CUT TO THE
ATP. THIS PROGRAM IS ESSENTIAL
IN SUPPORTING CITIES, ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS AND
PUSHING THE STATE ONE LARGE STEP
CLOSER TO DELIVERING ON CLIMATE,
MOBILITY, PUBLIC HEALTH AND
EQUITY OBJECTIVES. FOR THAT
REASON, WE RESPECTFULLY URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT RESTORING
THE PROPOSED 600 MILLION IN
REDUCED FUNDING FOR THE ATP IN
THE FISCAL YEAR 2425 BUDGET.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, SENATORS TERESA COOK,
ON BEHALF OF EQUINOR, ONE OF THE
CENTRAL COAST OFFSHORE WIND
DEVELOPERS. I SPEAK TODAY IN
REGARD TO THE REDUCTION IN PORTS
FUNDING FOR THE ASSEMBLY OF
THESE VERY LARGE TURBINES. THIS
IS A REALLY TIME SENSITIVE,
CURRENTLY CRITICAL APPROPRIATION
THAT WAS GRANTED IN 2022. IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO STAY ON OUR
DEVELOPMENT TIMELINE, TO HAVE
THAT PORT READINESS AVAILABLE
FOR US AS WE ARE DOING THE
UPFRONT WORK TO GET THESE
TURBINES IN THE WATER. SO TO
THAT END, WE REQUEST A
REINSTATEMENT OF THE $20 MILLION
REDUCTION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON. MEMBERS. ROSS
BUCKLEY, ON BEHALF OF VENTURA
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION, SANTA CLARA VALLEY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY AND
OMNITRANS, WE WANT TO THANK THE
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR YOUR EFFORTS TO
PROVIDE 5.1 BILLION TO TRANSIT
LAST YEAR. WE URGE YOU TO
APPROVE THE FUND SHIFT FROM
GENERAL FUND TO GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND FOR TR, CIP, AND
APPROVE THE ZERO EMISSION
TRANSIT CAPITAL PROGRAM TO MEAN
THE 5.1 BILLION FOR TRANSIT
AGENCIES. THESE DOLLARS ARE
CRITICAL FOR THE AGENCIES THAT
WE REPRESENT, SHIFTING TOPICS,
ALSO ON BEHALF OF SOUTH COAST
AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT,
WE WANT WE ARE APPRECIATIVE OF
THE AB 617 PROGRAM FUNDING BEING
PROVIDED IN THE CAP AND TRADE
EXPENDITURE PLAN FOR AIR
DISTRICT IMPLEMENTATION AND
INCENTIVES, ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE
MAY REVISED REVENUE UPDATE.
HOWEVER, WE REQUEST THE
CONTINUED PRIORITY
PRIORITIZATION OF AB 617 FUNDS,
WHICH PROVIDE TARGETED SUPPORT
FOR DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN
TERMS OF IMPROVING AIR QUALITY
AND PROTECTING PUBLIC HEALTH.
CURRENTLY, AB 617 PROGRAM IS
SEVERELY UNDERFUNDED AND WE
DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
SUPPORT THOSE EXISTING
COMMUNITIES, PARTICULARLY IN THE
SOUTH COAST REGION. WE HAVE TWO
THIRDS OF THE STATE'S EJ
COMMUNITIES, AND THOSE ARE THE
ONES THAT ARE HARMED THE MOST BY
THE REDUCTION IN RESOURCES, TO
HELP ADDRESS THIS, WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT AB 617
PROGRAM FUNDING BE RESTORED TO
LAST YEAR'S LEVELS. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON,
JORDAN CURLEY. ON BEHALF OF
AMERICAN CLEAN POWER, I'M HERE
TO SUPPORT OFFSHORE WIND AND TO
ASK YOU TO NOT CUT $20 MILLION
RIGHT NOW FROM OUR PORTS AT A
CRITICAL JUNCTURE FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE BUILDING, WITHOUT
PORTS OFFSHORE WIND DOESN'T
HAPPEN. THIS IS REALLY CRITICAL
FUNDING THAT IS NEEDED NOW.
WOULD LIKE TO NOTE, THOUGH, THAT
WE DO SUPPORT THE NEED FOR
CONTINUED STAFFING AND
PERMITTING NEEDS AND TIMELINES.
AND SO JUST THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND URGE YOU TO REINSTATE
THAT. 20 THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, SYLVIA SOLIS
SHORE HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
SOUTH. EXCUSE ME, SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
DISTRICT, WE ARE HAPPY TO SEE
THE FUNDING FOR AB 617. HOWEVER,
WE ARE DISAPPOINTED IN THE
PROPOSED ELIMINATION OF FUNDING
FOR THE FARMER PROGRAM. IN A
RECENT REPORT, THE LÀ IDENTIFIED
THAT PROGRAM AS ONE OF THE MOST
COST EFFECTIVE ONES TO ACHIEVE
CRITERIA POLLUTANT REDUCTIONS
AND GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION
REDUCTIONS AND ONE OF THE MOST
DISADVANTAGED PARTS OF THE
STATE. THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY.
WE ASK THAT MEANINGFUL AMOUNT OF
FUNDING BE RESTORED TO THIS
PROGRAM. I'M ALSO HERE ON BEHALF
OF ADVANCED ENERGY UNITED.
ARGUES THAT THE COMMITTEE REJECT
THE PROPOSED REDUCTIONS TO THE
CLEAN ENERGY RELIABILITY PROGRAM
AND ZEV PROGRAMS. THE DEMAND
SIDE GRID SUPPORT AND
RESIDENTIAL SOLAR AND STORAGE
PROGRAMS HAVE HELPED REDUCE PEAK
LOADS AND REDUCE BLACKOUTS. THE
DBA PROGRAM WILL ALSO HELP
FURTHER THIS GOAL. WE ASK THE
COMMITTEE TO MAINTAIN FUNDING
FOR THE FUELING INFRASTRUCTURE
GRANTS AND DRAYAGE TRUCKS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE CLEAN TRUCKS,
BUSSES AND OFF ROAD EQUIPMENT
AND ZEV SCHOOL BUS PROGRAMS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. GOOD AFTERNOON. CHAIR
AND GOOD AFTERNOON, SENATOR
BLAKE. SPEAKER I'M KAREN STOUT
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE SANTA
CLARA VALLEY WATER DISTRICT, WE
CONTINUE TO BE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE CUTS TO WATER AFFORDABILITY
IN THE STATE BUDGET,
PARTICULARLY WE ARE CONCERNED
WITH THE CONTINUED WITH THE
CONTINUED CUTS TO WATER
RECYCLING PROGRAMS, AS WELL, WE
ALSO SEE THAT THE PROPOSED
CLIMATE BOND AMOUNTS WON'T MAKE
UP FOR THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT'S BEING CUT. SO WE'RE
CONTINUING TO BE CONCERNED ABOUT
OUR WATER AFFORDABILITY EFFORTS.
WE'RE ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT CUTS
TO DAM SAFETY, AS WELL AS
RECYCLED WATER FUNDING,
ADDITIONALLY, WE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE EAF SHIFT WITH WHICH
CUTS ESSENTIAL PUBLIC SERVICES
LIKE FLOOD PROTECTION, WE WERE
HEARTENED TO SEE THAT THERE ARE
INVESTMENTS IN SEA LEVEL RISE.
WILL WE CONTINUE TO BE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE ADEQUATE FUNDING FOR
THOSE PROGRAMS? WE URGE YOU TO
RECONSIDER THE CUTS. AND THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SENATORS ERIC THRONSON, ON
BEHALF OF SACRAMENTO REGIONAL
TRANSIT DISTRICT, NORTH COUNTY
TRANSIT DISTRICT, SUNLINE
TRANSIT AGENCY AND LIVERMORE
AMADOR VALLEY TRANSIT AUTHORITY,
WE ACKNOWLEDGE THE DIFFICULT
BUDGET, TIME AND GREATLY
APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS TO HONOR
YOUR COMMITMENTS TO TRANSIT.
THOSE FUNDS ARE ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL TO THE CONTINUED,
SAFE, EFFICIENT, AND RELIABLE
OPERATIONS OF OUR SYSTEMS. WE
REQUEST THAT YOU SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO SHIFT THE
SB 125 FUNDING FROM THE GENERAL
FUND TO THE GRF, SO THAT OUR
TRANSIT SYSTEMS CAN PROVIDE THE
MATCH NECESSARY TO BRING HOME
SIGNIFICANT FEDERAL DOLLARS AND
CONTINUE TO INVEST IN THEIR ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE TRANSITION,
SPECIFICALLY, SAC RT IS USING
THE FUNDS TO MATCH OVER $100
MILLION IN FEDERAL FUNDS.
SUNLINE IS EXPECTING OVER $35
MILLION AND IN CTD RISKS LOSING
$53 MILLION IN A RECENT FEDERAL
AWARD FOR ONE SPECIFIC PROJECT
WITHOUT THESE MATCHING FUNDS.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR, FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF TRANSIT. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, SENATORS,
ON BEHALF OF THE SAMANTHA
SAMUELSON, ON BEHALF OF THE
BUILDING DECARBONIZED COALITION,
WE ARE DISAPPOINTED TO SEE
FURTHER CUTS FOR FUNDING FOR
BUILDING DECARB IN THE
GOVERNOR'S REVISE. AND WE
REQUEST THE STATE MAINTAIN
FUNDING FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION'S EQUITABLE
BUILDING DECARBONIZATION
PROGRAM. THE EBD PROGRAM IS THE
FIRST OF ITS KIND PROGRAM THAT
HELPS LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS
ACCESS COMPREHENSIVE HOME
RETROFITS TO IMPROVE INDOOR AIR
QUALITY, HEALTH, COMFORT AND
ENERGY AFFORDABILITY. ALL WHILE
FURTHERING CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE
GOALS. AND THEN ON BEHALF OF
CERES, I'M HERE TO THANK THE
GOVERNOR FOR HIS PROPOSED
FUNDING FOR SB 253 AND SB 61
IMPLEMENTATION, AND URGE YOU ALL
TO CONSIDER MAINTAINING THAT
FUNDING IN THE FINAL BUDGET.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, TASHA NEWMAN, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
OF LAND TRUSTS AND THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICTS,
WE'RE HERE TODAY TO SUPPORT THE
PROPOSED FUND SHIFT FROM GENERAL
FUND TO GRF FOR THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD. THAT WOULD
PROTECT $213 MILLION OF CRITICAL
FUNDING FOR PROJECTS WHICH ARE
ALREADY IN THE PIPELINE. WE'RE
ALSO HERE TO EXPRESS CONCERN
ABOUT POTENTIAL CUTS TO THE
HABITAT CONSERVATION FUND, WHICH
NOT ONLY FUNDS WCB, BUT ALSO,
STATE CONSERVANCIES AND I
BELIEVE STATE PARKS, WE WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR CONCERN
FOR A CUT TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSERVATION, CLIMATE SMART LAND
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM, WHICH, IS A
CUT OF $7 MILLION, WHICH HAS
ALREADY BEEN, APPROVED FOR
GRANTS AND, THE PROCESS FOR THE
GRANTS HAS BEEN ONGOING FOR THE
PAST SEVERAL MONTHS. AND THE
GRANT AWARDS WERE JUST MADE AND
KIND OF COINCIDE WITH THE BUDGET
FREEZE LETTER THAT WAS SENT. SO
WE WOULD VERY MUCH LIKE TO
PROTECT THAT FUNDING. IT WILL BE
FOR RESOURCE CONSERVATION
DISTRICTS AND TRIBAL
ORGANIZATIONS AND THEIR
PARTNERS. SO WE BELIEVE THAT
THAT'S CRITICAL TO MAINTAIN.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I'LL TAKE
BACK OVER. THANK YOU. SENATOR
DARLING. GOOD AFTERNOON. ABIGAIL
SCHMIDT, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION, I'M HERE TO TALK
ABOUT TWO PROGRAMS THAT DON'T
REQUIRE A LOT OF FUNDING, BUT
WERE CUT AND HAVE A REALLY BIG
IMPACT, THE FIRST BEING THE
STATE PARKS, LIBRARY, PARKS PASS
, THE PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN STATE
PARKS AND THE STATE LIBRARY,
THAT PROVIDE FREE PASSES AT
PUBLIC LIBRARIES FOR LOW INCOME
FOLKS TO BE ABLE TO ENJOY STATE
PARKS. IT'S A VERY CHEAP PROGRAM
, ONLY COSTS A COUPLE OF MILLION
DOLLARS. IT, UNFORTUNATELY, IS
SLATED TO BE CUT. AND IT'S BEEN
WILDLY SUCCESSFUL OVER THE THREE
YEARS THAT IT'S BEEN
IMPLEMENTED. AND THE SECOND
PROGRAM IS THE $6.7 MILLION
PROPOSED CUT IN THE MAY REVISE
TO THE STATE PARKS SEA LEVEL
RISE, ADAPTATION PLANNING MONEY,
THIS IS OVER HALF OF THE 11.5
MILLION THAT STATE PARKS RECEIVE
FOR CLIMATE ADAPTATION PLANNING
IN THE ENTIRE NATURE BASED
SOLUTIONS BUDGET OVER THE THREE
YEAR PACKAGE. SO THEY DID NOT
RECEIVE A LOT, AND OVER HALF OF
THAT IS BEING CUT. IT'S REALLY
CRITICAL THAT WE CAN RESTORE
THOSE THOSE SMALL PROGRAMS THAT
HAVE A BIG IMPACT. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR, AND
SENATORS. ROSANNA CARVACHO
ELLIOTT HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA GROUNDWATER
COALITION, IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO SOME ADDITIONAL
CUTS PROPOSED IN THE MAY REVISE,
THERE'S AN ADDITIONAL $100
MILLION PER $100 MILLION
PROPOSED TO BE CUT FROM WATER
RECYCLING AND GROUNDWATER
CLEANUP. THIS IS IN ADDITION TO
THE ALMOST 175 MILLION PROPOSED
IN THE JANUARY BUDGET, BRINGING
IT THE CUTS TO 275 MILLION FOR
WATER RECYCLING AND GROUNDWATER
CLEANUP. VERY IMPORTANT
PROGRAMS. AND IN ADDITION, THE
MAY REVISE ALSO PROPOSES TO CUT
ADDITIONAL MONEY FROM PFAS,
CLEANUP. AND AS I THINK
EVERYBODY KNOWS, PFAS IS A HUGE
ISSUE THROUGHOUT THE STATE FOR
OUR GROUNDWATER BASINS AND AT
THE END OF THE DAY, SOMEONE HAS
TO PAY FOR THIS CLEANUP BECAUSE
THE STATE IS PASSING, MANDATES
ON WHAT THE MCL HAS TO BE FOR,
FOR PFAS AND WITHOUT STATE
SUPPORT TO HELP WITH THE COST OF
THAT CLEANUP, IT IS GOING TO
FALL ON WATER. RATEPAYERS AND SO
THE TOTAL BETWEEN THE MAY REVISE
AND THE JANUARY BUDGET, IN CUTS
TO PFAS CLEANUP IS $130 MILLION.
SO A LOT OF MONEY THERE. THAT
AGAIN WILL END UP ON THE BACKS
OF RATEPAYERS. AND I KNOW
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF DISCUSSION
ABOUT ELECTRIC RATEPAYERS, BUT
THESE ARE WATER RATEPAYERS AS
WELL. AND THEN LASTLY, THE
PROPOSED CUTS TO SIGMA
IMPLEMENTATION OF ABOUT 1.4
MILLION IS ALSO VERY CONCERNING
AS A GROUNDWATER ASSOCIATION WE
WANT SUSTAINABLE GROUNDWATER AND
WITHOUT SIGMA BEING IMPLEMENTED,
YOU KNOW THAT'S JUST NOT GOING
TO HAPPEN STATEWIDE. SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. HELLO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M FATIMA
ZUBIATE FROM CALIFORNIA.
ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS. I'M HERE
TO JUST REITERATE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO REJECT
FURTHER CUTS TO THE CLIMATE
BUDGET, PROTECTING THE CLIMATE
IS ABOUT PROTECTING EQUITY AND
LOWERING THE ENERGY COSTS FOR
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS AND
COMMUNITIES, WHETHER IT BE THEIR
CAR WITH CLEAN CARS FOR ALL,
HOMES, WITH EQUITABLE, EQUITABLE
BUILDING PROGRAMS OR UTILITY
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE PAYMENT
PROGRAMS. ANOTHER PRIORITY FOR
US IS ENDING OIL AND GAS
SUBSIDIES, ESPECIALLY THROUGH
LARGER PROGRAMS LIKE THE WATER'S
EDGE, ELECTION OR RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT, WHICH CAN
POTENTIALLY REDIRECT BILLIONS IN
FUNDING FOR THE STATE'S CLIMATE
GOALS AND PRESENTS A VIABLE
ALTERNATIVE SOURCE OF REVENUE,
SO WE URGE YOU TO PRIORITIZE AND
PASS A COMPREHENSIVE,
INTERSECTIONAL CLIMATE BUDGET
THAT INVESTS IN RESILIENCE,
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND CLEAN
ENERGY. WE NEED TO SEE MORE
CLEAN ENERGY INVESTMENTS IN THE
ASSEMBLY'S CLIMATE BOND IN ORDER
TO MEET OUR CLEAN ENERGY GOALS,
WE MUST ALSO PRIORITIZE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE PRIORITY
PROGRAMS IN A CLIMATE BOND,
WHICH HAVE AND HAVE
OVERWHELMINGLY BEEN CUT IN THE
BUDGET. BUT WE ARE REALLY
EXCITED AND GRATEFUL TO SEE SB
253 AND 261. THE TWO CLIMATE
DISCLOSURE LAWS FULLY FUNDED IN
THE BUDGET. SO WE URGE YOU TO,
YOU KNOW, KEEP THAT FUNDING, THE
LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN SUPPORTIVE
OF FUNDING IMPLEMENTATION FOR
THESE LAWS. AND YEAH, WE JUST
WANT YOU TO CONTINUE TO HAVE
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THIS. THANK
YOU. HELLO, KRISTEN GORI, ON
BEHALF OF THE MIDPENINSULA
REGIONAL OPEN SPACE DISTRICT,
EAST BAY REGIONAL PARKS
DISTRICT, THE LAND TRUST OF
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY, SAVE THE
REDWOODS LEAGUE, AND THE
SEMPERVIRENS FUND, WE WOULD LIKE
TO THANK THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR THE FUND
SHIFTS TO GRF FOR THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD ALLOCATIONS
IN THE MAY REVISION, BUT URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO RESTORE
FUNDING TO THE STATE, COASTAL
CONSERVANCY IN THE BUDGET.
FUNDING FOR COASTAL RESILIENCE
HAS BEEN CUT BY 392 MILLION,
WHICH WOULD DRASTICALLY SLOW
DOWN OUR PROGRESS IN BUILDING A
CLIMATE RESILIENT COASTLINE,
PREPARING FOR SEA LEVEL RISE AND
REACHING OUR 30 BY 30 GOALS BY
PUTTING THE FUNDING BACK, WE
WILL BE GETTING OURSELVES BACK
YEARS ON IMPLEMENTING PROJECTS
ON THE GROUND. WHILE WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT SOME BUDGET
CUTS ARE NEEDED, THIS IS NOT THE
PLACE TO MAKE THEM. THE
RESTORATION OF THESE FUNDS IN
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET WAS A HUGE
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION, AND
WE URGE WE URGE YOU TO NOT TAKE
A STEP BACK. ADDITIONALLY, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA HABITAT
CONSERVATION PLANNING COALITION,
IN OPPOSITION TO THE EARLY
SUNSET OF GENERAL FUND
ALLOCATIONS TO SUPPORT THE
HABITAT CONSERVATION FUND, THANK
YOU. I APPRECIATE EVERYONE WHO
TESTIFIED. WHEN I THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR FILLING IN HERE
FOR ME AS WELL, IF YOU DID NOT
GET YOUR COMMENT, IN, YOU CAN DO
IT IN WRITING, ON OUR WEBSITE,
COMMENTS ARE IMPORTANT TO US,
AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE TESTIMONY
IN THE OFFICIAL RECORD. AND
THANK YOU TO ALL THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND LÀ FOLKS WHO
PARTICIPATED HERE TODAY, WE'VE
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA. AND SENATE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE TWO IS
ADJOURNED